two
michael jackson
hmm
what's up wednesday
july 27th
okay it is ethan klein
[Music]
damn grand thing with you what's up dude
[Music]
hold it young figure thank you for the
three gift the rope ah
no
no
yeah
no
yeah
yeah
no
no
oh wow
oh my god
what was the run time on that
pretty long aren't they uh 25 seconds
maybe we should put a cap on the run
maybe maybe 15 seconds yeah okay i can
show you that's strong yeah uh that's
not a criticism your work is is uh i
mean you're the rembrandt of
chaotic intro music
thank you thank you but um i will
shorten it next
off the rails
yeah yeah we're off the rails yeah um we
have no sponsors which
yeah
yeah
yeah
what is happening bro we have no
sponsors like all the time
um
i think you guys know what happened
i'm just too much of a maverick
that's true
yeah we took the title from uh from our
boy logan but
does logan paul ever get sponsors though
on his podcast
probably
i feel like i've never seen one
do you watch impulsive
of the episodes i've like opened for
reference i don't think i've ever seen
a sponsor
let me tell you about it
um
welcome everybody we don't have a
sponsor but you guys will be happy to
know that tomorrow
morning at 10 a.m pst if you go to
teddyfish.com you'll be able to get this
elon musk is a piece of [ __ ]
rock it
be it
live it
dream it
and of course uh jeff bezos
is a penis will also be available
tomorrow so
that's pretty hype
would you wear this shirt in public i
would proudly hell yes oh yeah yeah
would you down of course
you wouldn't wear that about it
you hate him more than anyone here yeah
no that's true you're not if i want like
the words piece of [ __ ] like on my shirt
it's a little vulgar
olivia yeah it's not christ-like it's
not that bad i mean no it's i've seen
more vulgar shirts in public the dick
one i guess i would be more hesitant
actually yeah that one i i i
i think they're both wearable i think
they both straddle the line yeah yeah
but wearable
definitely thank you guys thank you for
supporting me of course olivia's giving
confirming nods
love is giving confirming knowledge i
even or i mean maybe i heard love
chiming in yeah that means a lot
dan [ __ ] you dude
screwed me again
just kidding
[ __ ] you um
yeah
as the title says
we got another strike this time from
pork boy that son of a [ __ ]
pork [ __ ] pork penis
you know i was just getting ready to
settle the beef with him
you know i was thinking he might be
bestie material
and then this [ __ ] happens
like what wasn't i warming up did i say
nice things about him you were you had
softened on him a little bit in the last
time i think you liked that he had
pushed back on uh on oh yeah paint a
little bit which is that's the clip yeah
uh they took downs yeah he did a good
job on our a decent job on tate
and i even said by the way
uh he had a
huge w take on the abortion
uh it was the rover suede repeal he was
quite upset about like i was like damn
this guy's kind of based
um
you are seeing sponsors [ __ ] yeah what
kind of sponsors do they have uh agency
box
what the [ __ ] is that
uh
sports betting
world's first automated marketing tool
what the [ __ ]
automated marketing tool what the hell
is that [ __ ]
let's take a look at logan's sponsors
guys by the way do not contact this is
not about trying to contact the sponsors
don't even take it there guys i'm just
genuinely curious who's sponsoring him
agency box man this isn't a real company
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for having me just declare that bro look
at this [ __ ] a second agency box is the
world's first automated marketing tool
that gives you access to everything your
business needs to grow
i'm saying see geek
see geek okay that's a legit one
agency box allow you to start or grow
your business in the world
oh lead generation
yeah it's like a sales tool
this is kind of funny this is like a
total marketing to like crypto bro
[ __ ] you know what i mean
they got that crypto bro market
lead generation
what we don't have we don't have
aspiring entrepreneurs in our audience
like he does that crypto [ __ ]
you disagree
i think uh there's there's plenty of
business owners in our audience we know
we know oh you're just gonna backing me
up today dan i mean what's this l after
all
i'm i don't know how i'm gonna do the
show like ethan you're so combative
agency box is sponsoring podcasts maybe
we should play
yeah oh [ __ ] love agency box yo
they also have a ridge wallet i'm saying
we love ridge we love race you know i
use ridge
ridge
i used to work with ridge and sea geek
yeah but i think we love them all
you know what dan you make a good point
dude
agency box
you have a lead right now yeah i got a
lead the h3 podcast you know what man
you are so right and by the way we have
a ton of entrepreneurs in our audience
oh yeah that are looking
yeah for tools yeah see uh the ellen
organic i'm a business owner turn up we
need that's right we need tools
yo we need [ __ ] tools right now
yeah everybody's see i know the chat's a
little delayed but they're still in ldan
mode no this is this is not an elbow
moment what's funny is
whenever people say i'm surrounded by
yes men i was like do you ever [ __ ]
this is literally a no man yeah
i find that man
the man does not support me on anything
the only yes man here i would say
is probably zap yes
i love that people always say me but
it's it's not it's definitely definitely
i mean sorry zach i gladly take that
title yeah no and he's yeah and i love
you thank you i think you're more of a
yes man maybe than like
dan right ian who's like just a hater
right
yeah but you're not a yes i'm a good one
i wouldn't say i want to say you're a
yes man yeah
yeah oh thank you no
it's funny whenever whenever i have a
bad idea zack's the only one that's like
do it bro
that's actually happened a number of
times where ethan will pitch something
and everyone in the office will be like
yeah i don't know when zack's been i
think it's great and ethan
correctly he's like if zack's the only
one back right i love tuning in it's a
red flag i love to ensue chaos
but then sometimes i say let's do it
olivia
olivia is running for the title though i
have to say she's not a yes woman but
she is a she's like joker chaos like you
got me into some [ __ ] bro it's a little
joker brain i know
what i want
you know
i know what i want to see
i know what the people want
yeah i followed your advice once or
twice and regret it olivia
you're my boss that's saying
but anyway that's nearly here nor there
we were talking about something oh yeah
pork boy
poor [ __ ]
so our episode
called it's so dumb this whole process
of [ __ ] stupid
called uh the teddy brush controversy
yeah
so they did a claim on it
we were talking about when the bff
podcast had taint on
and i mean you had that you wrote the
details in that email it was like we
talked about it for a couple
minutes
yeah uh very very transformative was uh
that the part that they actually struck
in the back end i think only says like
50 seconds and three and a half hours
right and the amount of pausing that we
did throughout that means the actual
footage views was significantly less
than that it's obviously fair use were
commenting about this phenomenon
happening right now about andrew tate
the segment wasn't even just about their
podcast it was also about other people
that had had him on right in the larger
context
and i'm like bro is this just a spite
strike because what happened is they
claimed first the whole [ __ ] podcast
three and a half hours
uh for like 30 seconds and we say well
no
uh we're going to dispute it and then i
don't even think they came back they
just came back with a strike right or
did we do a second i think that there
was already a two-time bounce back and
forth and so yeah this is them taking it
to the next level i guess
so barcelo said
you know what
your three and a half hour podcast
where you used our clip for 20 seconds
if we can't make all of the revenue off
that then we're going to give you a
copyright strike because that and i mean
how scummy does it get
i mean how
[ __ ] could be common misunderstanding
or mistake how is that a miss you
literally it's like
filing a dmca is a legal
is illegal i just thought we were trying
to
yeah
what's with you today dan i don't like
you right but before the show i got i
got to be honest
uh you know a little bit gentler i got
to be honest okay
the thing is it's a dmca it's a legal
document so you have to it's not a seri
it's not something you can you know
really mess up
because you have to like file put in
your company name address sign it and
basically acknowledging this is a legal
document now
um
yes so they took down the whole [ __ ]
thing and then well what happens is we
file a counter notification now
and now i thought it came back up once
it was a counter notification but we
have to wait ten mother loving days for
that [ __ ] to go back up i mean what the
[ __ ] bro
that's that does not make sense
that does not make any sense to me
because we're basically saying we accept
the risk that they're they're just gonna
have to sue us if they want to do
anything about this so why the [ __ ]
should i have to wait 10 days for my
content to come back up right it's so
punitive
it's so over the top actually i haven't
even gotten a dmca strike in so long
because usually people just do the
global block
but they just they went for it yep they
went for it
um i i was really racking my brain
trying to remember
if we dealt with this before and i
i vaguely remember it happening once a
long long time ago like three four years
ago on the podcast
yeah like i said it's really fallen out
of favor because it's an unnecessary
risk and the global block is so easy you
don't have to fill out a legal document
or anything
and so poor [ __ ] um
[Laughter]
so i think it must have been a spite uh
strike and it's just so pathetic you
know this whole [ __ ] business who
they have their own podcast by the way
and they watch clips all the time on it
they [ __ ] rely on fair use and for
them to come and strike our whole
[ __ ] podcast because we used a clip
of their show is so hypocritical it's so
[ __ ] up dude
it's absolutely
[ __ ]
absolutely it was the one it was a
couple weeks ago it was called teddy
fresh controversial controversy and i
don't know what else was in it but
i'm checking again and yeah it's still
not there it's ten days it's gonna be
ten days until it's up
yep
and oh god
uh uh dave uh taylor said dave poor [ __ ]
and his weird crew were very rude to
cooper
on the bff podcast who was very vocal
about struggling with his mental health
please look it up interesting
or coop
shout out cooper bro got out cooper
brother in arms
yeah it's so scummy dude it's so scummy
it's like so scummy can you imagine and
i like
bro
and i was just starting to be your homie
hit the warhorn zack
dave poor [ __ ]
this is a shout out
we shall not surrender
we shall not uh
ride
poor [ __ ] oh my god
loves embraced his nordic we will fight
this on the beaches
we will fight this in the air
ban the barricades we will fight this on
the internet
we will fight this on wikipedi wikifeed
we'll fight this on wikipedia just
kidding i don't have any control of that
that has nothing to do with it right
like that very quickly it was just
wicked it was a word association right i
feel you
we will fight this on all battlefields
and hopefully i can get into another
lawsuit with a billionaire he's not a
billionaire but he's rich
also famously
extremely stubborn yeah litigious so
well he started it i mean what the [ __ ]
bro he's got a one point three right now
on wiki feet oh oh pull it up hold up
let me see that idiots with the wicked
feet
enough i'll pull it up
but the thing should we wait to see if
the piece could possibly be no no this
is what i was saying
has been thrown bro the gauntlet has
been [ __ ] thrown we've been dealing
with this for weeks they have repeatedly
abused the system and now taken down our
video the gauntlet has been thrown
with dave portnoy you already have a 1.3
i can't even lower it your feet are so
disgusting oh my god
show me some pictures
now don't open them bro what are you
doing what is it what are these photos
you're trying to do like foot
fetish porn
man the barricades
and i was just warming up man i was
saying nice things i was saying i like
your pizza review and that you had some
basic takes
it's not too late to salvage this one
star everyone knows the rules
yeah you guys know what to do boys boys
and girls
you can't lower it anymore it's already
all the way down
report the page get it taken down
completely
bro yeah shots are fired the gauntlet
has been thrown paul revere is running
to [ __ ] warn the troops the british
are here it is time to fight
for our independence
man the barricade for our freedom
our free speech shall not be infringed
by ryan cavanaugh
or dave pork dick
[Applause]
man the battle station
but this thing yes you know what i
happily litigate this one and be the
easiest dub of my life
let's go bro
pay for my fees
then you ryan cavanaugh can make a
support group together and [ __ ] cry
about it
i shall not be overtaken
freedom for the war we want freedom for
the world
i'm stealing it
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway thank you uh let's get some feet
in the chat
everybody let's get to the let's get
this in the chat because it's time
dude this is me right now
waiting freedom for the walk
is that a video or just a picture
it's just a picture
i love that guy i need can we find him
and get him
on the show to be my like a war hype man
he fire i don't know if he would
appreciate uh leftovers
yeah but whatever that guy's probably if
he googles you he might be a little
upset something tells me he
he's probably in jail for insurrection
he might be in jail
for the world
all right so that's what's going on you
know luckily the copyright strike is a
separate
bucket
then the
community is strike
yeah so we didn't get we're one and one
i don't think you get in trouble for
maybe you're doing i don't know for the
copyright strikes oh it says in the
thing that it there's not like a
escalating punishment the way there is
with um
the community guidelines where you know
you can't stream for a week and yada
yada but it says if you get three
copyright strikes within 90 days they'll
terminate the channel yeah so what rules
you sons of [ __ ] i don't think i
think if you're disputing them that that
doesn't happen
but
um because it would be so easy to get
someone's channel removed for some dumb
[ __ ]
but uh
up yours woke moralist
dave we could have been friends man we
had so much in common i love pizza
i love abortion
right
okay
you know
i love abortion as much as sandra
bullock
you both
think that
women shouldn't be in sex slavery
is he pro sex slave no i'm saying he's
anti oh he said yeah i mean that was
where he drew the line with him i'm anti
yeah the bar was very low but he did
manage to cross that bar
you know what i'm realizing though
with uh mike tana
and jeff my three best new besties
coming on the podcast next week
is that
this whole stint with frenemies has
really i have like caught i have so many
enemies after all that not a lot of
enemies
got a lot of enemies
how's that go trying to drain me in my
energy trying to drive me up my energy
no but i was a hater ass [ __ ] that
whole year i'll be honest like
because i don't know it's just so
contagious with you got i mean trisha's
going to war every damn second over
every little thing and i was just
writing for her you know
but now i got a lot of enemies
got a lot of enemies there's some
bridges to repair i was a hater ass
[ __ ] yeah for sure you were going to
war with like
non-people like like
hair by j like who the hell is that
[Laughter]
he was rude to trisha he was very rude
to trisha i think he did like it was
justified he was a scary like on his
life i remember he was really mean oh
yeah i remember he had the meanest like
name oh he was pretty nice yeah he was
[ __ ] remember that
damn
did you think of that right now yeah no
i just planned it last night
wow it's in a duck i was playing i was
planning that one
um
yeah
i gotta i gotta make
i gotta make some progress here in fact
i have david dobrik scheduled to come on
the show next week too
yeah
just want to know how he's doing through
all this
check in
but uh no i'm really excited to get the
can uh the three besties in here should
be real fun good time
you know
i do know
um
god who else did i burn like i'm totally
burned with from frenemies oh do you
want you wanna i would because i think
now's the time i'm in like my my how
many separate
steps are there in the alcoholic [ __ ]
yeah i'm doing like 12 steps we have to
go one of the steps is apologize to
everyone i i seem to recall this
wouldn't be up to date but um
in uh i'm getting ready to pause last
year ian put together a pretty
comprehensive list
for the road when he like pulled down
the scrolls by the way um i'm enemies i
i'm prepared to apologize to dave pork
noy for poor [ __ ] for the intro
so
we'll see if that if we make i'm just
saying the road is open
all right dave poor [ __ ] you hear it
he's looking come on he's a funny guy he
gets it he's got a sense of humor mm-hmm
what give me the list yeah
let's see some of them let's see yeah
here you go leafy is here um steven
crowder no logan paul jake paul greg
paul
jeff whittick joe rogan now hold on hold
on hold on
i mean all those people suck i mean
maybe
maybe
i'm not john i'm not done i was gonna
make exceptions okay except jeff who's
my best friend now
and like there's a lot of people in
there
and then i think i don't know maybe we
went too hard on joe rogan
it's hard to say the thing about joe
rogan is that
he's friends with so many of my good
friends that it makes stuff kind of
weird sometimes
so i don't know it's like one of those
things where it's like should i just
like
not talk about joe but at the same time
it's like he's such an idiot
[ __ ] you
all right you got it
well anyway joe i don't joe probably
barely knows i exist so it's not really
an issue
um
but you know like tom sagar is a good
friend of mine and like you know he's a
obviously a good friend of joe's too
he's always on his show and stuff and
whitney too
yeah whitney who's coming up well yeah
whitney's coming on the show
but what was it there's someone else in
there i wanted to jeff whitake you
wanted to jeff what if uh
this someone else uh
of the ones i listed already i think
that was it
but i mean there's there's more names
what there's a lot more names do you
want to keep going yeah what would you
say i said there's ninja oh we'll get to
ninja yeah yeah
scotty i probably i don't need beef with
scotty i definitely don't need beef with
scotty who's who's forgive me who's
scottie he's a he's the dubric guy who
christian was like
she's like he made a song glorifying
mental illness
he didn't really i mean it wasn't that
wasn't what it was about what is it
about him taking his antidepressants
wasn't it no and he made a video
calling
he had this screenshot of seth
oh yeah that was pretty rough he ended
up deleting the video and you know that
was pretty rough that was pretty rough
scotty but he seems like ultimately a
nice guy i don't need beef with scotty
so
uh beef beef is resolved scotty we're
good i mean i i i i release it forgives
you i release the beef and i apologize
for anything i ever did to you that was
a little that was kind of shitty what he
did but it's all good i mean we all [ __ ]
up right i'm not i'm no saint who am i
to judge an older grudge which leads me
to my next person which is a b is on the
list what did you do
i was around that time that people were
saying mean you had beef because the
tricia situation oh yeah well abe's
forgiven me yeah best friend material
abuse you know come on okay thank you
yeah um
killer
yeah what about hello
we're gonna have you guys you guys are
you guys are jumping they'll headaches
ahead
vitaly
so someone says don't blame trisha fair
enough i mean obviously i made i'm i i
made this decision petty [ __ ] of my own
volition
so i'm not i'm definitely not trying to
uh
pass the blame on to her i'm just
coming to terms with my i'm on the fir
the third step right now right but yeah
i mean no no not it's not trisha's fault
i just got lost in the sauce i think
so this one isn't on the list but the
demilios
i don't think i ever beefed with them
you know trisha kept trying to go in and
i i feel like i defended yeah at one
point you were like i was like
you know i was like charlie you gotta i
don't have beef with the dumilies in
fact i think they're i think they're
totally fine i don't see anything wrong
with them like
compared to some people who are of that
stature of fame i mean they're they're
fine and charlie just seems like a nice
normal girl i got no problem bryce hall
i don't know if i have a beef with bryce
hall necessarily bryce hall on gun
do i
i don't i mean yeah i don't think
there's too much of a beef there
i feel like that started when he had all
these corbett parties probably or am i
wrong yeah yeah and then they did like a
year in review on frenemies i think
bryce hall moments
okay but i don't i i'd have no beef with
bryce okay yeah because since you
tweeted at him and said podcast and he
said yes yeah i guess nothing ever came
oh you know what i think he wasn't yeah
yeah it was a covet thing i think it was
yeah but i'm open to having him on what
do you guys want me to be good yeah i
can dm him too or maybe you try i don't
know but yeah shut up bryce hall i mean
a little bit of a douche but with peace
and love
like he wouldn't take offense
but he knows he's a little bit of a
douche doesn't he
probably that's like his stance it's
like a yeah
dan what you feeling with peace i don't
know
i
i can't get i have to admit i i i still
don't think i've seen like a second of
any bryce hall content i don't i don't
really know anything about him i just
he's just i saw him got beaten up by
austin mcbroom my boy yeah austin
you know i keep going this is
interesting okay bill burr
i don't beef with bill he just destroyed
me he just gave me trauma okay sam
tripoli sam tripoli [ __ ] that guy idiot
nobody gabby hannah oh that's
interesting a little bit that one gabby
i have no problem with gabby yeah i
don't think she ever did anything like
so wrong that
in fact i'll just be i think gary is
being cringey yeah being chris no i mean
exactly
i think gabby got kind of stiffed in the
whole thing like maybe our word
apologist or maybe apologies
there's i guess there's always something
but we all [ __ ] up we all say dumb [ __ ]
i mean she didn't r-word anybody no but
it was her best friend her best friend i
don't know yeah it's [ __ ] up
[Music]
yeah that one's tough that one thing is
tough but she just got dog piled so hard
by so many people
so she betrayed her best friend and said
yeah and in support of the guy who
assaulted her
um boiled down yeah pretty much wow
that's that's that's some like real
housewives level of betrayal yeah that's
crazy
i don't know yeah we don't okay we don't
like gabby sorry gabby we're saying no
nick nish yeah people hate gabby in the
chat
people are saying do not forgive gabby
okay
all right there you go get [ __ ] gabby
whatever you guys want
whoever you tell me who to be mad at
so the remaining names aren't really in
front of me is related so i don't know
if i should keep going keep it going
okay um some ordinary gamer udahar well
that's varied okay anything for views
that's old oh jay simpson
[ __ ] oj
uh
nikita dragon
that's old i don't know dave portnoy
dave pork boy right now i'm saying
[ __ ] dave but but maybe we'll see
there's a light there there may be a
path
redemption there yeah perhaps yeah uh
craft mayo
craft male [ __ ] craft man thank you oh
crap [ __ ] [ __ ] man dude i'm forgetting
damn unforgivable go ahead oh my god
who pyrocynical
oh no that's old stuff okay uh
the michael jackson fan base
oh i'm not gonna condemn a whole fan
base jesus christ
but i do say [ __ ] michael jackson i will
never change that
but i don't blame people who are like
fans i mean i get it there's enough
plausible deniability maybe
to
like maybe delude yourself but he
definitely did it i mean come on
soflo antonio a [ __ ] so [ __ ]
hey hey hey he he was nice enough to bro
take a
take an ugly girl on a ferris wheel that
was you know big still one of my
favorite podcast moments of all time
that was huge of him
go ahead shoot nice
being too nice are dogs he's just joker
brained yeah it's yeah i've been
snorting drained one thing yeah
prank invasion
fake invasion [ __ ] that guy that guy's
in [ __ ] some predator prison right
now rotting making out with his mom no
dude that guy is [ __ ] bro
the state of texas oh the whole state of
texas well that that's that that's too
far obviously i don't like the elected
officials of texas yeah perhaps the
governor and the governor the senator
i think it's hot in texas it sure does
uh but there's a lot of great folks in
texas we love texas
beautiful state
that is all the names on the list there
are a few in chat well there's got to be
way more yeah i'm seeing jason nash
vitaly i mean [ __ ] vitali
uh shane dawson and ryland adams
yeah i got it i think i got to say
[ __ ] shane dawson
[ __ ] him yeah i gotta say [ __ ] shane on
that one
ryland i don't i don't care about ryland
but i mean [ __ ] him by association i
guess
run train on them
it's like that you got any more
uh let's see um
can you say the somebody said the
bradberries come on no oh we're good
with no bad berries
yeah oliver tree i will never forgive
right fousey
i
don't
have a problem with fousey to be honest
i never really did
i'm not super familiar with his lore
fouseytube because i know like everybody
[ __ ] hated him was there ever like
what was the worst thing he did besides
fake pranks
yeah i don't think he ever did anything
like irredeemable i think it was just
very cringe stuff
it tastes like beef jerky and that's
that stuff is like beyond is like of
course forgivable man uh i always
thought fouseytube was one of those
people that just got [ __ ] dog piled
on yeah i felt bad for him i just think
he blew up too quick and just needed
some help
could we say he redeemed himself with
that sound bite of the beef jerky
well he's
50 50 owners i mean game i think yeah
he's he's kind of gone down the dark
side a little bit but
we'll see but i i honestly i got no
problem with fousey
phase blanks
face blanks um
i think i think
you know
blanks there's a there's a path of
friendship there thank you for saying
blanks
blinks
i like blanks yeah i i i i'm turning on
blanks
especially since he ended that podcast
and doesn't seem to have association
anymore that's a big step for for him
patrice wilson
i have well that that beef is so ancient
yeah
that be you guys remember patrice wilson
there's been like a whole new angle
it's so which is kind of crazy it is
that's why it is yeah it's cool i'll get
into it patrice wilson was like old old
old-school
h3h3 productions this guy he made um
friday he made friday
and he would always insert himself into
the raps
and like super creepy shots like this
his videos were so nuts but ultimately
we made fun of him for being cringed
which obviously isn't a crime but i
think when he really
took things way too far
as he made this music video called uh
goal uh uh
what's it called i know it was this girl
allison gold that blonger that was in
that photo right it was called
what was it chinese food right
no it wasn't chinese food it was the one
when she's at the prison and having like
an orgy
there's one where she's at like a mental
asylum oh a b c d e f g is that the name
of it i don't think so no
you guys remember that i made a whole it
dude it was the craziest thing and he
got he got like widespread media
attention for this
but she's like you know 10 and she's in
like tiny outfit super exposed and then
there's tons of like almost naked adults
dancing and it's very sexual in nature
and it got widespread um media attention
and lots of comment literally every
commentary
channel made a video about that leafy
was the one that started calling him a p
word
and then uh i don't know bro and then it
got super weird like he started like
threatening us
one of the weirdest sagas
he did a countdown timer where like he
with my name on it he scared the [ __ ]
out of me scared me so much i had to go
drive out of my house and go wait at a
parking lot yeah that was uh some very
very early podcast lore that a lot of
our newer viewers may not even know but
that was a legendary stream where we had
post malone on yeah and patrice did this
whole coordinated bizarre
like coded
did like arg experience almost where he
had these videos with like creepy
footage of like an abandoned farm in the
middle of nowhere crank it people yeah
that was called crank it i don't even
know if you can find the video online
anymore you could probably find
reactions to it but boy that video is is
like um
uh deprived i mean it's really messed up
i remember that stream it was hilarious
dude it was scary i couldn't tell how
like scared you guys actually were i
wasn't they were legitimate because i
know
that yeah a post was like i knew for
sure like once the stream was over dude
i left my house yeah they were like they
were like afraid to go home holy [ __ ] i
mean he was seeming he was like stalking
you in real time
right
and then the thing was
that he made a video afterwards saying
like calling me out and saying he wanted
to on alive himself and stuff
and you know obviously
that's horrible to hear i i personally
don't know why he targeted me
when i felt like there was other people
that he was the main thinker out of the
time of the internet like yeah then
there was so many people talking about
it and like i guess your
video did get pretty popular but i think
leafy did a ton of videos on them that
got a lot of views and with literally
the title like this guy is a literal
people you know right yeah
literally
obviously i think it's
sad to think that i that i could result
in it but i do think that it is
important that this guy's not working
with kids and make i actually do yeah
after you watch that video i think that
you know it's important he's not working
with kids anymore and and we're making
video content like that because
i
there was something really [ __ ] up
going on there and it was very obvious
right and i that's why i understand the
videos defending the whole situation
because you guys were calling out that
he was sexualizing these kids like oh
well she well the people who are saying
so now that the whole people are trying
to start this narrative that like
uh
patrice wilson is like some poor
defenseless guy that i almost drove to
unaliving himself
i dare them to watch that music video
right react to that music video and then
tell me how effed up i am but anyway the
patrice thing was was so wild and i mean
the crank it one was the what happened i
found it she found the music video it's
not on youtube it's on it's off site i
don't think we can yeah i don't think we
can show it either but it's uh it's on
vimeo
yeah
oh shush up shush up yeah and the thing
is like he had made
[Music]
several
very questionable videos leading up to
this
and then um
this one really put the the nail in the
coffin so that's an interesting one but
i don't i don't have beef with him you
know i just hope that
i do i i honestly think he was a danger
to children around him i'm sorry but if
you watch that video there's really no
other conclusion yeah and by the way it
was so heinous
that youtube removed it and i think
banned his channel and he was getting
widespread media attention so like
to put it all on me is kind of wild like
i didn't even respond to that video
didn't react to it so long after all
that drama had happened right i was
super late to the game on that video i
remember
yeah he has chinese food you know
they're all super weird people are
saying uh goku naruto i don't care about
him i mean that's all ancient history
[ __ ]
um
what else
i mean people are throwing out random
things those are the were like the
standouts uh billy dee and shapiro
obviously obviously bestie not saying
sorry that shapiro [ __ ] forever i hate
that guy
um
buggy
i don't know because i made like one
little comment and then he like [ __ ]
lost his mind he's been like [ __ ] on
me for like a year straight now like
totally unhinged
hate posting so
uh
i can't say that i
think boogie is bestie material
in fact i might even say [ __ ] boogie at
this point
wow i don't know i might even uh just
gave that man content for months
well he's already he's already saying
what he will yeah exactly uh
people saying garyvee
garyvee no you know what
might be a nice guy might have helped
people i really think he's a scammer bro
i mean really he really is scamming you
guys and it's crazy the guy is selling
napkin drawings for
50 000 to his
adoring fans yes i really think garyvee
is not a serious he's not a serious
person
you know jason nash is an interesting
one because
i feel like we would get along well at
like
i like him as a person but there was no
resolution with with the seth thing
which is
creating an obstacle for me
there
but i i do like jason now she seems like
a good guy but if you you don't ignore
all that [ __ ]
um
but you know at the end of the day
he just got sw i think he must have just
got swept up and all the dobrik stuff
because they were all under his spell
jason and all those people were just
kind of doing whatever david wanted so i
don't know
there's one right there how about
deal break did you say that right here
dobrik i mean [ __ ] dobrik obviously yeah
um
little tracy
a little tracy i didn't remember what
our beef was but shout out little tracer
where there was never beef we're huge
fans of little tracy and then every time
you mentioned him he would get really
upset and say
keep his name out of your mouth and [ __ ]
and shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah we were
just yeah we never said anything bad
about him at all like ever yeah that was
a pretty fun one
yeah crystalia i'm super torn on
i had i had such a nice relationship
with him he was on a show so many times
and honestly he was so sweet and funny
and really a great dude
but the accounts that came out just make
it really hard for me to
and i've always talked about them like
this so i don't i can't say we have beef
i mean we don't but
that one is kind of a i just you know
it's kind of hard to get over certain
things like that
matt haas [ __ ] matt hawks
chet hanks i wish you know what i could
me and chet should be dogs
i paul i would bury the the beef with
chatty boy
there's chat i'm calling out to you man
what was the beef
we were honestly we were just making fun
of his axe his his roster thing right
and then he threatened us with physical
violence and dms right
but but that was a bit much i wish that
um
i wish that we were dogs
ice beside him i i don't have beef with
ice beside i don't know he seems like an
idiot though
that he was never like a character on
the show
no yeah
yeah and we talked about him scamming
people
did we kind of had that one arc
yeah the the he like rock pulled
something
i don't know oh
yeah something with like the sam pepper
dude
right wasn't he involved
it was actually more recent he has like
an mp
crypto thing oh right oh yeah yeah i do
remember and he was just like honestly i
don't give a [ __ ] stole your money yeah
it's kind of fun yeah james charles [ __ ]
oh come on dude james charles oh bro are
you kidding me it's on site
yeah james charles is on site
come on dude that guy should be in jail
agent khalid why are you saying that he
that's a mean me and cal are dogs yeah
he's been on the show before yeah friend
of the show roman atwood i think i was
overly mean to roman atwood i mean i i
you know i was very critical of roman
atwood
but the prince well he did some really
[ __ ] up pranks back in the day it was
a long time ago because he was all about
that prank and the hood [ __ ] that's what
was so racist and messed up but that was
so long ago
um i don't have a problem with roman you
know i
i actually have some something that i
kind of reacted on it and as regarding
roman atwood i watched his mo he started
a podcast and he had his dad on and they
were talking about
uh beating and belting their kids
which
and they thought it was good yeah it's
super wide wait pull it up
hmm
let me know let's
let's
well now hold on i gotta i make an
informed decision here before helen
keller of course [ __ ] her
liar what is she going to do hear me say
this she's not even going to see her
hear me
a liar and a fraud
mobility mary i wish yeah i wish we were
friends right now
it's so tragic that she's gone ripped to
the ghost
biggest loss
you know we tried so hard to recover her
scooter we did we actually even we got
so far as to getting a hold of uh
somebody it was somebody who was like
handling her estate we were stuff and we
tried to get the scooter and it was
already gone we were two weeks late yeah
two weeks [ __ ]
that would have just been very such a
relic man god damn it
such a relic
did you find anything about the
roman atwood i'm looking for the
timestamp but the reason i reacted to it
is because
his kids are on video their whole life
and now he's like
saying that
hitting your children is not that bad
i'm looking for it though
well anyway we have
obviously a whole show to do and we
don't need to but yeah that clearly i
have a lot of amen i have a lot to make
yeah and ta and one and one above
all is a ninja
right
this man has done nothing to me
and i have continued to make fun of him
we said that he looks like a middle-aged
woman
and you know he always say nice things
about ninja he came on our show
at the like height of his popularity he
came on this show he didn't have to
and you know i really appreciated that
it was a cool cool thing to do
speaker thank you for the three gift the
rope
thank you for the gift to pick
appreciate you
thanks for the dental bro
um we'll get into that but oh ian's
hitting you with more receipts more
things to apologize ninja texting scam
yeah to bring it on bro because i have a
lot this is all going out to you ninja
oh and then let me show you the clip
that actually broke my heart
uh where's the one where he says yeah
here watch this we i saw this and it
made me sad dude watch this [ __ ]
did you see that the h3 podcast loves
you who's the h3 podcast are you talking
about
if you talk about ethan klein he does
not like me
i do man is there a different podcast on
his h3
[ __ ]
bro i love you man
he's so sad dude
it is i i i feel bad honestly i'm such
an [ __ ] what is this clickbait link
man hold on
and then i see the chat the crew loves
you yeah well that's good at least yeah
he's reading chat
thinking
the crew loves you
well i i
it's even kind of people who work on his
podcast
well i must okay so much so the people
who work for him well that's great to
know
we love you nina bro you gotta we gotta
watch this like sad music in the back
yeah
i i
this morning
and this was entirely unprompted too
like i didn't i didn't bring it up
some some random chatter brought up and
he started reacting to it i don't think
he knew that was me responding to him
there
and i felt bad yeah i don't think he
needs any music it's sad enough bro i
feel bad he's a ninja you know and then
ninja had this same kind of thing where
he like catapulted to success
everybody loved him and then all of a
sudden
all the commentary channels were like
[ __ ] ninja and he really didn't do
anything yeah he's that bad he didn't do
anything bad i don't recall any
controversy with him you know
um
i guess yeah yeah i really and then well
let's see what was this
uh texting scam let's see this was you
remember this was the
a lot of influencers were doing at the
time i think he just was one of the
first or the first that we saw where
people were giving out their
phone number by the way i haven't seen
that in a while that [ __ ] i think just
went away yeah
yeah well because it's really dumb it's
a dumb idea
that's you want to get spam
text messages
all the time well also he says i'm
giving you my phone number that's
literally not what's happening
yeah the other thing is that like his
wife threatened to sue pokemon and stuff
but i mean look this dude look again we
all make mistakes we all [ __ ] up they
didn't sue her nothing ever came of it
we can't hold people we can't hold
things like that over people's heads
forever we all [ __ ] up and being an
influencer is stressful and sometimes
you do say dumb [ __ ] that you regret
doesn't mean you're a bad person it
definitely doesn't mean that you're
irredeemable we all do dumb [ __ ]
things dude it's not fair how we hold
[ __ ] over each other's heads forever
especially something as
as trivial as that
you know what i mean compared to like
[ __ ] james charles does yeah ninja
ninja's a [ __ ] good dude bro it was
horrible the way we treated him shame on
me stop saying we
no yeah i included you guys i include
all you guys excuse me no no no no it's
easier for me
that's not okay we standing no dude no
i'm standing here no
no
do not co-sign out no well hold on let
me see what i said about him
watching this clip i'm gonna be like
talking mad [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing uh
what is he doing i'm saying [ __ ] salt
face still
ian said it was off the hook off the
hook thank you him yo why didn't you say
that on the mic he just muttered it
under his breath
oh
stan why
you got to contribute to the show if you
got oh god now here comes that wait wait
you want to be in court
wait did you wait hold on was this a
setup
i didn't send this link
wait what
wait no no who sent this link somebody
set me up the link's gone it was ian
yeah why the [ __ ] is this stinker i'm
saying [ __ ] in bro
no no no did you just skip forward
because i
you're being a little stanker dude no
i think you're setting me up wait hold
on okay let's see if ian's actually
setting us up or not why'd you delete it
i you
i don't see any ninja references
so all i see is ian wait i'm confused
because i
i just clicked
the top ninja link copy link address and
then i sent it
wait you didn't timestamp it the
timestamp is still in the link so if you
just click copy the link and paste it
again you're going to get come to the
time span yeah so this was where someone
left off content you connected
that is what you sent yeah this is what
you said okay i didn't try that's
actually kind of funny though because i
didn't try to do that but
you just skip around and it happened
yeah me and ian had like a pseudo beef
or i was like i don't know i was doing
this shtick where i was like super mean
to him
and i thought it was funny but it wasn't
really i mean i was just trying to show
the thumbnail people thought i was
extremely serious i think people got
really mad at me once i think ian's
trying to say something i think there's
someone else he wants to know if you
have beef with still
with ian yeah i don't have beef with you
and i love ian
ian's a [ __ ] mega talent bro less
than honored to have him on the crew are
you kidding me
super funny guy yup
one of the i mean one of the funniest
it's just incredible how he's blossomed
into
um
it's like a rose yeah he's blossomed
beautiful incredible
comedy writer his switching is on
otherworldly
you changed the title yeah i sent you
it used to say ninja looks like why does
ninja look like a middle aged woman the
new title is
ninja is an icon
yeah which i think we can all agree on
ian thank you for the gift of the title
um
so
well anyway thanks for [ __ ] setting
me up you know is there actually any
time stamped i really don't think ninja
related that is kind of funny though but
anyway whatever um
yeah ninja you're you're the man bro you
know what
i do like you
in fact you've been shouting out
you've been shouting us all out
we started a project
this all started by accident he gave a
shout out to was it cam first or cameron
yeah he gave hey shout out cam grant
damn grant secretary what's up dude yeah
and i thought that was just so cool
that i wanna i put the guys to the task
to try to get one for each crew member
yeah well this one
these four this one was from a fan this
wasn't even one of us actually oh yeah
so look at he said my full name man
ethan klein thank you for the five
dollar dono
you're very welcome bro i'll take credit
for that
so yeah shout out so shout out from
ninja
thank you
um
let me just cut in real quick i totally
lost track of time because we have gone
totally off the rails uh already
for this episode um we actually have a
guest that's supposed to call in like
right now yeah get him ready and then
i'm just going to uh finish this because
i just want to show you guys okay
lena thank you for the gifted ian slater
that with your one sub a b stock killer
thing with the prime exactly the gift
sam temple think of the gifted sub dan
from h31
what's up dude
yo that's almost everybody
so how much did you guys spend go dude i
was curious how much it cost to get him
to shout at us all out i just did a
prime sub i think sam spent the most oh
sam how much did you spend she she
stepped out but she um
she spent 25 and he didn't see it so
then she spent another five
30 bucks to get it the 30 bucks for the
shout out you put that on my card right
and you guys put that on my card
everyone kind of everyone said they
wanted to support yeah i did it well use
my money to support him no let's
we're being serious we love ninja here
he's earned our money we we gave it to
him direct from our own pockets
you know we did we did notice that
twitch lets you gift up to uh a hundred
subs
which is 500
youtube's max at 50. yeah
so um if you really want to make it up
to ninja i'm just saying
i'll do that i'll do that 500 is he live
right now he's not
um
100 subs man not that he needs the money
there's another clip in here that we
skipped i need to give some credit to
love because we did this after love was
uh working him for a little bit to get a
shadow for all of us
in one clip
i've been chatting with him a lot
[Music]
wait oh for love so this was all you
love but no there's another clip in the
dock i have it highlighted oh yeah loves
love kind of got cheese
yeah
okay
so he he really sees your chats in the
stream
yeah i've been chatting with him for
like two hours today what do you mean
chatting wait hold on hold on what do
you mean chatting
uh you know i just uh like one on one
hold on hold on hold on are you in his
like are you a live chatter are you guys
talking one-on-one live shatter okay
okay but he so he's acknowledged you
senpai notice you after 40 bucks
40 bucks
larry in this shot
young figure thank you for the three
gift the rope
in that first video where he was sad he
was reacting to me saying that he loves
him
he was wrecked into you what
he he was reacting to me saying the crew
loves him and that made him a little bit
happier yeah bro we all love you yeah
dude
you got done [ __ ] dirty dude by me
and lots of people on the internet
you're a [ __ ] legend dude
so
they will never be raised ever again can
you give a shout out to my family ethan
a b cam dan
gila
ian laina
he's probably just like what the [ __ ] is
going on what is with all this h3 [ __ ]
it has been there has been a campaign a
love campaign against ninja
from here yeah maybe you're bombing him
maybe our first love campaign yeah sam
zach
young up dude i really hope they're
still watching man i know it's in 16
minutes sorry i started eating i don't
check my donuts
he's so well at keeping up with his
donations i don't know how the hell he
does it to be honest he's positive
wait what did you
what did you get zach
i uh i subbed and then i gave him a one
gift sub oh okay okay so he said thank
you for the gift station yeah baby stock
killer thing with the prime
minister
abc
[Laughter]
i'll upgrade later you know
yeah
lena thank you for the gifted i hope
that name is gila it could be hilah it's
gotta be gila it could be ela
he's like holy [ __ ] i just realized who
it is yeah i know
i love it and like we don't talk about
all right we'll see we'll see we don't
talk about like what what it is until
that's the video so technically the view
that's it yeah yeah yeah there's another
clip that i sent to the discord i don't
know if you want to watch it i do i do i
want to watch everything he really
appreciates the love i guess
um
i think i would love to to make i'd love
to have him on
i believe you man i appreciate the love
dude so wait wait what's leading up to
this give me the content yeah so this is
after i because he said i don't know i
don't know if this is a troll or not uh
so i i had to come out i am one of the
h3 crew members and we do actually love
you uh
and this is after i said that
let's see
i i i believe you man i appreciate the
love dude to you and the whole crew
thank you it does make me feel like
really good
[ __ ] nina
[Applause]
bro he did not yeah i'm sorry dude i'm
on my hands and knees back to reach out
and sell those nice things man so i'm
begging [ __ ] stud dude
ethan why have you done this
and i've been on the receiving end of
all that [ __ ] and and you know i think
you got to go somewhere ethan
you got to walk over somewhere right now
yeah you have an appointment right now
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
there's another camera
oh what about the call though we have a
caller he's not here yet he's he's
actually
he's actually a ninja fan as well yeah
he's easy okay well okay he hasn't
called in yet he's not calling in until
you apologize to ninja wait hold on okay
okay you don't all right no i want to do
that i just don't want to be rude
tonight every skin that i've gotten
early access to it has it has been in
the item
that night he is in the waiting room
this is this isn't about us he just
joined
let's do the
let's get let's stay on point yeah i
mean so much so ninja that um
i feel that it's been a long time since
we took out the podium
and uh you know i think it's time for me
as i'm getting all long to tooth as they
say and old
long in the two yeah
you mean you're translating what that
means for me oh yeah no no for the
audience yeah
you think they're dumb they don't know
what the expression means
you calling our audience down no no no
no
um
37 by the way not that old
anyway you know
it's time i'm 37
look it up google me
um
you know there's some people that just
didn't deserve the the heat we threw and
ninja's top of the top of the list so
could join at me over at the apology
podium
uh it says ethan cline so yeah just say
you're 36
cam dan
gila ian laina olivia sam zach
it says that you are
it says that you are uh it does say that
you're 37 but it also says that you're
171 pounds
it says that yeah that ain't right so i
don't know if i can trust the age is
what i'm saying
if it's saying you're 171 pounds it's a
little easier to gauge yeah i guess
that's true that's true
i come before you today
as a reformed hater ass [ __ ]
and you know
look what have you done honestly that's
so bad
nothing
you made some goofs here and there but
who hasn't influencers that have been on
the internet with that broad of audience
we've all put our foot in our mouth or
done stupid [ __ ] what crime was
committed
who was harmed
nobody and that's so [ __ ] up that we
hold that [ __ ]
over each other's head we got to be able
to distinguish between bad really bad
[ __ ]
okay
and
basically a slight goof up
because there's a [ __ ] difference and
sometimes we forget
and we hold on to those grudges
and it's not right
no
it's not
play the thank yous please zach
i think the gifted
[Music]
stock killer thing with the prime
shout out to my family ethan a b cam dan
gila ian elena olivia sam zach
sam temple think of the gifted sub
play that short one just uh thank you
for giving it
exactly
can you just clip thank you for the
gifted
yeah that one's good
[Laughter]
listen listen guys
we have to change our way we can't
continue
to tear each other down like this okay
and
i listen i'm at fault
you know we love nina
i felt like
i felt like at times in my career i've
been dog piled on and i've asked myself
what and i've asked myself that same
question what have i done what crime
have i committed right to be getting
this much hate
like i've never i've never done anything
really bad have i
nope
no
what crime have i done that's
unforgivable
nothing nothing
you know
and so like i feel that and yet i put
that pain on others it's not okay i
think this is your first one going after
ninja that's probably the worst thing
you've ever done i would agree with that
yeah maybe you're right i'm trying to
make amends here but the truth is ninja
you're a good guy man you did a good
thing for me back in the day coming on
our show and i think you're i think
you're a great fortnight player and we
all love you here
and uh
uh
you know
beginning starts now uh you know
addiction starts with admitting you're
an addict and i'm a hater ass [ __ ]
and i'm just coming out and saying
i'm addicted to petty [ __ ] i just
sometimes you just gotta admission is
the first step in healing right and i am
a hater ass [ __ ]
so that's it that's all i want to say
okay so this one's for you ninja
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we love you nina
[Music]
i'd love to get him on a call and talk
to him if he's up for that i understand
if he doesn't want to
we could try we can try he's a busy guy
a busy guy ask him
we're pretty close yeah yeah
love
you better get that message out
yeah young figure thank you for the
three gift of the rope i want to be
bro
i do also want to make a correction you
said he was a great fortnites player
he's actually the best okay he's that
and you know what he's actually cracked
and you know what say that because let's
not take that away from him he
is the best fortnight player he did so
much for esports for the game
he did come on bro
not even exaggerating after he
acknowledged us in our costumes i played
fortnite
i won two games in a row yo you got
blood blessed it's true i can verify
that yeah
that's true
wow
can we go doesn't need to have a wiki
feet can we both boost that let's juice
that
let's juice that wicked can you pull
that up please
i want to prove to you ninja that my
blevins my love is sincere and my
apology is sincere it's like it does
pull that up
he's actually got a good score huh look
at that does he have nice feet pull yeah
okay i mean oh i bet c-man would like
those ones love said wow look whoa we
gotta send that to seaman that's the
c-man shot no that's that's crazy
wait can you okay uh un-ironically are
you in touch with him still zach uh dan
yeah can you just send him that photo
what do you think of these okay i'll do
that right now i would i guess i'd say
it's probably the greatest food i've
ever seen that's pretty good that's
pretty good pretty good i guess creative
good i guess pretty good
but guys if you you know if you guys
went and gave a ninja a five star that'd
be
because he has beautiful feet yeah and
let's just be real yeah ethan klein
thank you for the five dollar donut
i am banned on wikifeed permanently
unfortunately so i will be unable to
write it myself
is this the first time you've used your
powers for good on that site
uh well
yes i'll say yes i mean we've used it
for you know
one could argue french using the score
was a good cause i mean like boosting
boosting
oh yeah we boosted bobby right yeah he's
very insecure about his feet so does all
of her tree have a wiki feet because we
should take that one
probably
um all right okay probably or yes i mean
dan this is not one
i see one photo
i mean this this something has to be
done about this it's way too high bro
there's only one yeah that needs to be
yo these people are [ __ ] so sharp
dude they're like beat ninjas dude you
flash that [ __ ] for a split second oh
yeah they get it yeah but that his
foot's disgusting if you ask me
yeah that i think it's uh
yeah it's awful yeah it's awful one star
yeah
i mean i wouldn't say ugly or awful
that's too harsh i would just say it's
one star it's one star that's what i
gave him i i don't mean it's you know
i'm not trying to say anything here i
i'd wait and what i don't know i'm gonna
hold my rating and see if we actually
get those tickets i'll say that oh
you'll save it for that holding out
all right we do have a gas tuesday all
right so we have actually a guest lined
up
uh this is the doctor there's some
background here dr ids
he's my boy
i love him on tick tock
can you guys link his tick tock please
yeah in the section here
um he's the dude who i was trying to
tell you guys has been putting out fire
research saying that diet coke by the
way can i get a diet coke lena
for this segment
yeah i'm on it thank you
um
i just want to say he's been putting out
lots of research saying that diet coke
is not bad for you
at all it's all [ __ ] and so and
nobody wants to believe me and i said yo
this guy he's the real deal and so we
reached out and i'm so happy to say
that we have him on the phone dr ids on
instagram he's a great actually i love
his
his tick tock he basically just debunks
medical
bad medical info right and he always
cites sources and stuff very cool guy
uh dr ids on tick tock big fan would you
like me to let him in yeah please bring
him on all right setting it up
one moment please
and
hello there there he is dr edge the
legendary
dr ed thank you thank you
doctor are you on big soda's payroll or
something what's going on here
oh cut out mysteriously hmm intriguing
oh oh you're back
oh is it working now yeah yeah i mean
apparently i am being paid uh i've not
seen any money yet which is quite
unfortunate
um
but yeah if they could sponsor me that'd
be good diet coke
yeah so tell me about your your
background we're trying to figure it out
you're in the uk by the way thanks for
calling in with the time zone difference
there uh but maybe you can explain you
you're you're a mbbs and an mres
yes so uh the mbbs degree traditionally
it was actually two separate degrees so
it stands for a bachelor of medicine and
a bachelor of surgery
so what they've done is they've combined
that into one medical degree which is
essentially the international equivalent
of what you guys know as an md okay okay
so i am i am a qualified medical doctor
uh working in hospitals but then i also
took time out in between my degree
to get an additional master's degree in
nutritional research alongside medicine
and so is that where your kind of
expertise comes from because you're
always citing like
you know studies and sources you seem to
have a lot of really intimate knowledge
of a lot of this stuff does that come
from your uh
the m
the mris
yeah yeah so so the emres is basically
the cherry on top you know in in medical
school
uh there is a heavy emphasis on uh
critiquing and analyzing research papers
but then the m res were allowed me to
basically focus on what i was passionate
about so i did the entire year on
nutritional research specifically i
conducted my own research study and that
was really where kind of things came
together and that's why you see me talk
about research all the time basically
and
what was your um
your interest there what was your your
specialization
during the masters do you mean or yeah
well you said during the research you
were able to hone in on on your
interests
yeah yeah so actually my the research
study that i conducted during the year
of my masters was actually on the link
between depression and refined sugar
intake oh so how how diet affects mental
health and what did you find in short
so i'm look i'm so i'm going to publish
the study soon but i will tell you what
the results showed
so basically um simplifying it down
so refined sugar are things taken out of
natural sources and put into products
cakes biscuits candy drinks whatever
right and
for every 100 grams of refined sugar
intake you consume per day that
increases your risk of having a mild to
moderate depression by about 40
really you found that link
yeah so that's between
per 100 grams so obviously most people
in the west they would consume more than
100 grams 100 grams
yeah exactly
and 100 grams what in what time interval
so 100 grams of refined sugar across the
day
and then obviously that goes up again
when it's 200 that goes up again when
it's 300 and so on so yeah very
interesting whoa
man that's
that's gonna be huge um so what what
happens now it goes to like a journal to
get peer reviewed
yeah exactly so i mean i've got
when i'm a bit less busy hopefully in a
couple months i'll basically
uh put it towards different journals
maybe psychiatric or nutritional
journals and then they have a peer
review process they then tell me if they
want me to amend anything
um and then yeah hopefully it gets
accepted
and then so is that why kind of why
you're you find yourself commenting on
diet cokes because a lot one of the
myths that you hear about it is like
they're either they're both just as bad
or in some cases they say diet is even
worse than that [ __ ] because it's like
artificial
so yeah so it's a very interesting topic
because
i have no idea where people get the
notion
that a artificially sweetened drink is
worse than the full refined sugar
version i have no idea where that's come
from most likely headlines of poorly
done animal studies rat studies where
they're injecting
ridiculous dosages of the sweetener into
the rat and then you wonder why it
causes issues right
um
but the thing is you have to understand
that
when you replace the full sugar drink
which a lot of people like consuming you
know i used to love consuming uh full
sugar drinks
um so do a lot of people when you
replace those excess calories going to a
zero calorie drink
the amount of benefits you get just from
that substitution is massive as long as
you're not you know finding other ways
you know compensating with other you
just because you're not having that
sugar kick then you find yourself you
know having three extra biscuits and one
extra cake a day for example obviously
the benefit of the sweetener
is that it should
dampen down that sweet craving that
you're experiencing so you don't feel
the need to replace those extra calories
with something else so that's what we
see yeah
that's very interesting to hear because
i think it's like widely held
belief that diet coke is not better and
actually i think one of the widely held
beliefs that i hear is that actually
diet coke will make you more healthy or
people who dr
drink diet coke are actually gained more
weight than the people who drink yeah
that's that's that's based on rubbish
association science we literally have
everything we lit we literally have a
new
of 17 controlled human controlled
studies which means that the researchers
know exactly what the participants are
doing they know how much they're
consuming
of 17 individual studies showing that
those when you replace the full sugar
version with artificially sweetened
drinks
they lose more weight than if you
replace the sugar with water so going
from sugar to water you don't lose as
much weight going from sugar to
sweetened drinks
wow
that's kind of groundbreaking
yeah yeah no it is because when you
dampen down that sweet craving from the
sugar
you're less likely to find
you're breaking up thank you
we got you back you just broke up
no all good sorry i was saying i was
saying if you go from sugar to water
then a lot of people try to compensate
with other sweet foods and beverages so
that's that's the main benefit from the
artificially drinks now what would you
say so like someone like me
i don't ever drink
um sugared uh soda
and recently i just picked up
diet coke so i didn't have like a coke
depend like a normal coke dependence i
just added the diet coke to my diet in
that case what's your opinion about that
when it's not replacing it's just coming
into the equation
well
it so how much do how much kind of full
sugar drink did you use to consume on a
weekly basis roughly i i wouldn't i
didn't really drink sugar drinks really
ever fine
yeah okay fine so in that case it could
it it can still easily have indirect
effects because of the fact that you're
sipping on something sweet and it's
satisfying to you throughout the day so
you might see indirect effects through
your normal dietary habits anyway
perhaps you're snacking less perhaps
you're less likely to find a you know a
nice
sweet or chocolate or biscuit or
whatever
i wouldn't say there are any inherent
benefits like it won't you know in and
of itself it won't improve your health
neces
indirect way it can definitely help yeah
i was wondering more like the downside
because people you know the common
knowledge once again quote unquote is
that it's bad for you so adding it to
your diet even replacing nothing in your
opinion
has no downside
okay so
i so we need to be we need to be
specific about what we mean by downside
because in the scientific literature you
need to understand that you can't
formulate an opinion
based on one research study whether it's
observational controlled whatever you
need to look at the total body of
evidence
and then formulate a scientific opinion
based on lots of different observations
right
so i can confirm that at the current
moment with the body of evidence that we
have
there doesn't seem to be any negative
effects from most of the artificial
sweeteners when it comes to
cancer risk when it comes to
glucose glycemic management for
diabetics when it comes to blood lipids
when it comes to gut health and
if the evidence is just not strong
enough it's just nowhere near strong
enough and we have lots of studies
showing a null hypothesis meaning no
result so it causes no effect that's
that's just a game changer you know i
think that changes everything what do
you what do you what do you guys think
about this because i was saying i was
trying to preach
the gospel the other week and i says
listen guys
i saw this great doctor doctor it's and
he said go for it and yeah and then
everyone was like bro you're crazy yeah
but here we go he's definitely doing
call him a liar to his face dan nobody's
nobody at any point called him a liar
okay what i actually i actually do have
a question though um so i
also kind of remember when all of these
fear-mongering about aspartame and
artificial sweeteners started i it may
have started earlier than this but i i
came into knowledge of it i feel like in
maybe the late 90s or early 2000s is
when i started to like hear a lot about
that
what
was the basis of that then was it the
was it not to get conspiratorial but was
the sugar industry trying to kill
sweeteners and and sugar replacements
so the basis
usually stems from
rodent studies
so these are studies on rats
where you where you give them or inject
them ridiculous dosages
of an artificially sweetened component
whether it's um aspartame acetolophane
potassium
and they find that the rat eventually
starts to grow a tumor or they start to
become obese or something right and when
you look at the dosage that you're
giving that rat if you compare that to
humans you would need something
ridiculous like
50 cans of
you know diet coke for decades literally
for years and years
like just to make the point that if you
had 50 bottles of water right now
would drown and you would most likely
die
so
the the poison is in the dosage you need
to understand let me ask you this why is
it that these kinds of um research are
even published like what is the actual
value of doing something
where it's like obviously
uh misleading it seems like to give you
know that much
and then or or may or is it that people
just misinterpret it and then run with
it yeah
a mixture of both so
animal research in any scientific field
holds very holds a lot of weight it's a
very important field of research because
we can start to understand the cellular
mechanisms and pathways by which an
exposure acts on our body so meaning if
we want to understand how something
affects the human body
we can't just willy-nilly go and test it
on humans straight away we need to use
rodents animals different different
cell culture to start to understand what
mechanisms they might be acting on our
body and sometimes we give ridiculous
doses to see what happens when it
becomes toxic
right but then when headlines and the
media get hold of it because they're not
scientists they don't understand how to
phrase things right so they then end up
saying oh new study shows aspartame
causes cancer right and they leave out
the fact that it was 200 times a dose in
a wrap right so i can see the medical
benefit is like let's see how much it
takes
until it's poison
yeah and then the media is like yo this
shit's poison
that's real interesting that's that's
super insightful because because hume
research on humans go it's very
nutrition space to run a study on humans
until you've passed the ethical board so
you need to make it clear that you're
not giving something that is
deliberately harmful to humans
and the way you the way you try and
manifest that is by looking at the
animal data the cellular data the cell
culture studies to then present to the
board look this is how much it takes to
cause an issue we're not giving anywhere
near that so do you think this study is
viable
then we can start doing research on
humans and then we might see a negative
effect we might see nothing or we might
see a positive well
there was um
apparently some scientists
that believed
that drinking diet soda may increase
appetite
by stimulating hunger hormones altering
sweet taste receptors and triggering
dopamine responses in the brain
is that yes yeah
that's a very common myth as well um the
thing is there have been
there have been probably 60 70
studies looking at people that include
zero calorie low energy sweetener drinks
in their diet they don't see any
significant changes in their weight
especially when you use it to replace
the full sugar version because you know
how often you could argue that the
minority of people
if they even if they don't like
sweetened drinks then someone's not just
going to randomly start including you
know diet drinks into their habit
yeah you yeah so for example you're one
example but the reason they exist is to
reduce the calories from the sweetened
version
substitute right yeah so that's the main
purpose of it and the data shows that
this whole tricking the brain into into
you craving more that's just not
substantiated by any controlled data
really
doctor do you drink diet coke
i don't drink diet coke but i drink
a low calorie squash every day all day
squash what is that
so squash in the uk is basically like a
concentrated
juice
and
you add it to water
and it makes it taste like a packet yes
like kool-aid kind of a vibes
it's like soft
um and uh what do you by the way what is
your day job if i can ask
so currently i'm finishing my job in
psychiatry in the hospital
so
um i've also done general surgery i've
done geriatrics that's older people
medicine and now i'm going to
respiratory medicine at different
hospitals that's lungs and breathing wow
and are your parents super proud of you
you've accomplished so much doctor eds
yeah yeah i'd say they are uh both some
hesitancy
yeah
are they there are they mad you you that
you're not yet a ph or
you are a phd
what more can you do to make them happy
[Laughter]
the thing is they want me to carry on
down the uh traditional hospital route
oh my god where are you you can please
these these parents
yeah
both my older brothers are also doctors
oh my god what a family
well man i really appreciate you calling
in uh
i really don't have one he's been
gloating about this all for like a week
yeah but
and you know because i've been on this i
feel like diet coke is all good i've
been saying this for years i said i'm
gonna drink as many [ __ ] diet cokes
as i want and everyone's like oh that's
just bad for you it's gonna make you fat
donald trump once famously said i never
i've never seen a skinny person drinking
diet coke and i thought maybe he's on to
something
yeah that's that's what we call a really
poor
basically you see two things and you
just attribute them because you hold a
belief right
so the same thing can be said about
the number of movies that nicolas cage
appears in on a yearly basis correlates
with the amount of people that drown in
a swimming pool
so apparently apparently nicholas page
causes
no so so that's an example of a rubbish
association right yes so so donald trump
you know
it may not be right
well and also just just to let you know
that the acceptable daily intake of most
sweeteners for you ethan you wouldn't
it's up to about 20 to 25 diet drinks a
day let's [ __ ]
you hear that that's a challenge
um so anyway dr eds it's been a pleasure
uh thank you so much for bringing your
expertise and knowledge dr ids on tick
tock i love your account i love all the
the videos you make is there anything
else you want to plug
uh no nothing at the moment just uh my
instagram as well i'm trying to i
started that a year later
um by my own stupidity so
i need to try and build my audience
there dr ids on instagram this is the
same same handle there you go guys
follow it he's a great great great
account learning lots
thank you
thank you so much for calling in
appreciate that
god bless you thanks doctor thank you
thank you
it's been a pleasure thank you so much
guys thank you appreciate it
there you have it what a what a what an
interesting guy smart
so
i wish his parents were just more
accepting of his career
just you know i like that you tried to
kind of
dig into the
psychology
dynamic a little bit at the end there
yeah i didn't want to pry too far but
it's funny
uh but what a sharp guy man what a
[ __ ]
what a guy also that the chat is down
tremendous for for dr dude you guys
gotta get your [ __ ] together man
every [ __ ] time every time someone
walks on screen i mean he is a good
looking guy he's a very happy
hold on would you guys handsome he's got
an accent and he's a doctor i mean
that's a triple nice okay well let me
ask you guys this between our recent
thirst guess would you guys go with uh
pmp attorney
or dr ids who's more thirsty
who are you more thirsty for paul
maybe that's inappropriate yeah it's
inappropriate yeah
guys
but the doctor swaggers oh he's a lawyer
he just gets double swag that it's the
eternal
uh rivalry right there between lawyers
and doctors well we love them both
and uh by the way thank you to our saudi
benefactor he donated a hundred subs for
the the ninja fun
let's go
el nino
shout out is ninja is ninja live yet
he evidently only streams in like the am
hours
uh he's having a beach day
oh good he deserves it ian's sleight of
hand that's your one sub
he deserves it man
i see lots of uh people seems uh split
on pmp and the doctor it's kind of a
might be pull worthy let's the first
poll should be is it appropriate to do
the poll
so
so do the pull dan is it appropriate to
do a put this poll
on which doctor it's a little it's a
little objectifying but let's pull it
let's see it's a little objectifying
i agree let's get it let's get a
temperature on the audience here like is
a quote who's hotter pole appropriate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah who's hotter
paul
yes or no
yeah i'm agree with you it is it's
objectifying and and we don't like that
let's see if the
let's see if the audience agrees
is it objectifying
who's hotter appropriate or not
what the vote of oh pretty close
it's
the results are pouring in
the yes has it so far but it's fairly
close
noes have it at 43 percent
40
uh yes is actually dominating now 60
they want the pull down
so i know
traditionally we just go with ever
percentages higher but i do have to say
42 percent of our audience not being
cool with it is a fairly significant
chunk i mean yeah it's pretty big oh god
i want to know the answer to that but at
the same time let's just move on you
know
uh thank you rudy when did h3 uh thank
you rudy for the 50 gifted
when did h3 turn into beautiful ville i
don't know baby when you showed up rudy
my boy rudy rude rude
anyway so wow we've covered a lot of
ground so far so i mean shout out ninja
shout out dr id all day by the way did
you guys love that i did
like jokes aside about me simping for
dying right yeah no no it is interesting
and uh i mean he smashes
widely held and we have a lot of these
type of um
food debates on this show it comes up
often so i do
hope that we can um maintain that
relationship and maybe have him be a
recurring you know person that can
clarify some of these arguments that we
have
absolutely i think he i think it seems
like he i didn't even get that i i was
intending on asking him
[Music]
if eating four of these family sized
bags of salt and vinegar chips a day is
good for your health or not i say it is
it's somehow beneficial in any way
i say no problem you're gonna have to
back that up with some peer reviews
board yourself until you're right i
gotta say
what's up love i'm still a little bit
skeptical i gotta be honest bro he's a
doctor
what do you skip i do i do appreciate
his uh
knowledge and everything but i don't
know like the long term stuff
i don't know
i'll i'll go i'll go i'll go down with
you i'll go down with you i'm with you
all these studies cannot be pushed on
the animal studies i try to google a
little bit just now and there's some
more stuff that i'm still having
questions about column back
love
the man he's a medical doctor he's got
degrees he's an md he's a research
expert who are you literally writing
paper who are you
questions i'm a nobody but i'm i'm
worried it's like the confirmation bias
he doesn't even drink diet coke
see that's worrying to me
he's got he's got no he's got no skin in
the game i'll just say when i asked the
doctor he just said the research is uh
inclusive that there's
that's
okay now let's do a pull
um are you pro diet coke now or still
skeptical that's that's a good pull star
spur it's pretty law are you pro diet
coke now
yes or
no
[Music]
the options are pro diet coke
and still skeptical i don't need yes or
no that's a bad poll
i'm a little bit a little bit biased too
because through the show everyone knows
i'm a very very skeptical person
so i mean obviously uh that might come
into
question or whatever
drum roll you know what also kind of uh
i don't i mean i i guess you're still
within your right to ask the question
love but you have
probably the least
healthy eating habits of anyone i've
ever known in my life he's a young man
though not exaggeration oh yeah you slam
fast food like four meals a day he's so
young he's at that age where he can just
do that and i'm saying that's fine i'm
not making a judgment here but am i
gonna trust love or the guy with
multiple degrees in nutrition on well no
i'm not saying but listening either or
i'm just saying
uh i don't believe either or oh i just
i just don't think well what he's saying
is for sure what he's saying is that all
this hysteria about diet coke being bad
for you or worse there's no evidence to
support it
but by the way this is kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] up let's go lovely i'm still
skeptical is winning at 56
what is wrong with you people we just
had a medical doctor
he's got degrees he's got he's got he's
we're not saying we're not we're not
we're not saying okay we're not saying
he's wrong we're just saying that right
your personal experience goes against
the imperial evidence bro every time abe
braves someone drowns
that was exactly what he is i i think
there's probably medical animals on both
sides uh but he there's he just said
there's not
he literally says there's not he says
there's no good study that shows it's
unhealthy
that's not what he said he
yes it is we gotta get him back roll it
call dr it's back dude i'm gonna stand
by my point i i i i don't think either
or i tried it do you still doubt it if
it's uh healthy that's basically all
yeah
it's not healthy nobody thinks it's
healthy the question is is it bad for
you all i want to say i'm not uh i'm
still skeptical that's all my god i'm
saying all i want to say is usually i'm
talking [ __ ] to chat but i ride with you
guys today find out for once we're
aligned god bless you guys i ride for
you now
what are you just having special assigns
to the chat ab sorry sorry we have you
know we have
i'm trying to do a show here bro
with 20 enemies i'm just making amends
with one what you've made amends with 20
enemies with 41 000 is what you're
making all at once i wrap it up see
anything else you want to tell the chat
ab while you're on it go ahead it's your
show now
go ahead
you have the floor
i'll ride with you guys
that's it yeah i got a message to chat
go ahead whoever's got message to chat
chat how you doing today okay anyone
else that's it
i'll just be quiet
i mean i guess email him but it he is
like
just trying to follow his head i don't
have any empirical evidence or anything
like that so there's no point for me
like it's imperial evidence diet copium
people are saying i know
i have no grounds to say anything with
that being said i'm still a little bit
skeptical that's who i am i'm skeptical
about anything everything and that might
be a flaw i i
i i admit that but yeah there it is
that's that's wrong apparently you're
not alone i can't do anything here
well the man told me what i wanted to
hear
right so i'll [ __ ] ride for him i'll
[ __ ] ride to him to the death young
fika thank you for the three gift of the
rope thank you for giving bro
uh
wow look at that pour
let me see this because everyone's
always talking about it that is really
slow the problem is like the first floor
when you open the can is extra fizzy and
you don't want to
once it hits the ice it releases all the
bubbles i'll back you up on this that's
a great board i don't know
thank you i mean it's a serious pour
yeah some people might and say it's not
worth it for just a diet coke
but i i diff i actually
i can't it just doesn't taste anywhere
is good it felt the bubble if it goes
flat
facts
oh he's coming back there is his back
um i don't
ethan what happened on the last episode
with this poor yeah this one didn't go
so this one yeah yeah i did i remember
it i poured it all over the [ __ ]
place
including right behind the laptop how
did that even happen
wait you clipped this love this is a
clip
yeah i don't know
that's
[Music]
[Laughter]
do not waste that sweet milk
peek-to-cheek is pretty oh my god i just
see that yeah so you know that's that's
kind of what the theme is today we all
make mistakes okay sometimes you pour
coke on the table
even though you're a great pourer
[Laughter]
it's just what sometimes you disagree
with the phd doctor
exactly
um
he's
did he say that he was coming back yeah
he's he's coming right dr aids is coming
back love you better [ __ ] hide yeah
and a b you too
you put your neck out
i got you so so
we appreciate what you said but our
but our boy love here wearing a
jack-in-the-box hat with a bunch of
ninja uh fortnite dances on the screen
i'll take the issue with you well not
but it's not not to single out love and
maybe because 55 percent of the audience
do no no i think it's just being
phenomenal i just think it's a funny
visual uh this like this doctor versus
with a picture of pokeman in a tiny
frame
shout out to yo by the way i wanted to
ask you about this how many patties did
you get from mcdonald's showed that
picture 20.
by the way those patties look
bigger than the ones we get here in
america yeah i'm sure it's better
meat it's actually meat so how much
yeah i was talking about it on yesterday
i got 20. and i was talking about on the
show i felt a little bit bad like
throwing all this [ __ ] away so i will i
was planning on announcing it next
oh we lost your dollars
we lost you we got you back
all right so i felt a little bit bad
about everything like wasting food so i
said i would like donate a hundred bucks
to
action against hunger
so
what a good gesture what a nice gesture
just to kind of counteract what i'm
doing you know what a nice gesture how
many of those of those patties were you
able to eat i probably
ate
four or five when i got home right so
not even close huh
sorry
doctor is
standing by shall i let him bring him in
bring poor doctor edds and he comes
pours his heart out nobody wants to
listen
dr edds have you been watching
i just loaded it up and i'll see people
have got beef with the diet coke still
so there's yes this is an interesting
phenomenon a b and love two crew members
here they said listen i'm still
skeptical and then we did a poll of 12
000 votes
55 said i'm still skeptical of diet coke
what can we what more can we say i said
he's a [ __ ]
doctor what more can we tell them dr ids
this
okay
so anyone that opposes the argument
that diet coke is not safe and it causes
harm i want them to give me more
evidence that i'm citing you right now
off the top of my head okay love oh
no
say something wait hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on okay go ahead go
ahead doctor go ahead
arno grayling at our 2020 a meta
analysis of 26 studies showing no blood
sugar or insulin issues
alexandra our low back literature review
in 2019 showing no effects on the gut
you've got a new meta-analysis in 2022
17 control studies by glenn ettel
showing weight loss benefits blood lipid
benefits going from the full sugar to
the diet drink version
and you've got john peters at our 2021
meta-analysis of 60 studies
showing above
weight loss is significant in those that
substitute full sugar with sweetened
beverages and also another analysis by
javiardo
20 of another 20 odd studies these are
all these are all human
studies they are done on actual humans
not on rodents not [ __ ] rodents
if you want if you want to hold the
opinion that there is harm to it yes
then you need to provide me more
evidence than i've cited right now
absolutely okay so love your response
love is m.i.a oh can i i can't see love
can you no i'm back
uh that this was the most polite
disagreement uh or i'm not even
disagreeing to you uh but he called you
a black doctor
right right no
no
but i'm just very uh a cautious course
to do this i am worried that there's
long-term effects that we don't yet know
about
and that's basically it i'm not even
saying that it's uh that you're wrong
i'm just saying uh you know uh
if maybe take this yeah if i may step in
for a moment
yeah let me just be clear we're not
saying that you're wrong okay i think it
was more that ethan was um jumping up
and down like it was the word of god
we're just saying because it is the word
of god i have someone in my family who's
very educated who is a doctor and he
said that when i asked him about this
initially he said that the studies are
inconclusive you know because there's a
lot of different uh studies that have
been done on it now you may be more up
to date and i may even say that you're
95 most likely that you're correct can i
ask you a question maybe yeah the person
you ask your family is he a medical
researcher he's done he's doing a lot of
research you have a degree in medical
research he has a degree in human
regenerative biology
did i hear research in there from
harvard and he graduated from good for
him where the [ __ ] is his degree in
research do a ton of research at that
level right doctor it's back me up
yeah so i think i mean okay let me let
me just say
that what love was saying about the
long-term effects
it might at some point
15 20 25 years down the line even though
these sweeteners have been studied for
30 40 years so if there was any serious
effects we would have seen them by now
100
that's completely out of the question
but
there might be some associations with
maybe let's say a random type of cancer
right that's already pretty rare
later down the line we might see some
evidence coming out like there was a
study recently actually that came out in
a french population of 100 000 people
that showed um aspartame and
acetosulfame potassium which are the two
sweeteners actually found in diet coke
those sweeteners did show a
relative risk increase about 15
of uh total cancer over i think an eight
or nine year period something like that
right
but once again unless you understand how
to interpret that evidence
there are lots of issues within he which
i could talk to which i could talk to
you about with any harvard doctor
whatever i'm happy to debate anyone but
the point is
is that when you don't see a dose
response relationship so in that study
for example
even though the researchers concluded
that there's an increased risk
the group that consumed the most amount
of sweetener they had a lower risk of
cancer than the group below them
so if you're saying that that sweetener
causes cancer why wouldn't why wouldn't
the highest group that consume the
sweetener have the highest risk of
cancer
man you're responsible it makes it makes
no sense right right so
so that's that's one example of a study
where the researchers concluded there's
an increased risk but you have to know
how to dissect the research and apply it
appropriately right your response
but it's still possible that there's
negative effects well yeah it can be
said about everything
statistically doctor i'm sorry for
wasting your time with this callback
this was just so inappropriate
you know yeah we you've given us too
much of your time already
could i just say i want to make it very
clear i i drink a lot of coke myself uh
coke zero so i'm not even at the point
of not drinking it myself oh yeah
that
in my brain or in my head alone i would
think there might be something something
sketchy about this now me saying this in
front of how many people are watching
uh might sound bad because i can't uh
formulate any argument for my case which
obviously looks pretty [ __ ] bad i i i
i do want to say that but uh i don't
know i'm just a skeptic dude can i ask
can i ask can i ask where does your
skepticism arise from is it from
headlines other creators saying stuff
you know where does it come from or
you're good
i am just looking back at all these
things for example this is a super reach
take okay but for example cigarettes
again this is super richie but
cigarettes were
called not bad in the beginning
what was the uranium watches uh was said
not to be bad at the beginning and then
it came out health effects this is just
my bias or my
and also it's super tasty and i
associate everything tasty with
unhealthy that's just my my mental thing
well you know and and i'll face i think
the problem is on face value
it's a little weird like there's no
sugar but it's super sweet you're
drinking a chemical
and you know i think we have some
preconceived bias that like that's just
[ __ ] weird that can't be good for you
yeah let me let let me just briefly
touch on because the smoking point is
actually a very
come back
it is
uh yeah it's because it is unethical
to conduct any controlled trial on
humans where you're giving one group
where you're where you're forcing them
to smoke for 20 years and you're forcing
the other group to not smoke right
so so the research on smoking is purely
observational meaning you look out into
the population and you see what happens
with people that smoke and what people
that don't smoke however with sweeteners
we have controlled evidence where the
researchers can monitor your every move
and what you do so it's not an absence
of data we have the data and the data
shows no serious negative effects so the
smoking point is actually a good point
that a lot of people have however the
logic can't be applied because we've
done the higher quality research which
is called a randomized control trial
where you actually tell one group of
people to do something and the other
group to not do something else
go on
uh sorry just to play devil's advocate
and help these guys or i just want to i
want to make sure we bury this
so i think they're saying
they're like well you know this
artificial sweetener's been we've been
in use for what 30 years approximately
what if
love you think that it's possible that
the effects have not shown themselves in
30 years yeah
you think
because there's people who have been
drinking this for 30 years well
okay so could i add just a little bit to
that and again i'm not arguing with you
necessarily i'm just stating why i'm
kind of skeptical don't feel bad this is
great you're you're you're wrong
i'm not getting no no people just don't
don't worry about this is good with this
we want to get to the bottom of this
love you're doing great so
you two have 30 years
during these 30 years
way less people like okay let's say
literally 30 years like there was so
little amount of people actually
drinking these substances
comparison to now when literally
probably billions of people are exposed
to them so
during those 30 years there's a less
chance that we catch uh what's wrong
with it uh
in comparison to now when
say one billion people are exposed to it
weekly
uh yeah yeah going forward
that's that's that is actually a
commonly held point as well however
with observational research it's very
easy if you wanted to conduct a study
you know looking back over the past 30
years all you have to do is recruit
those who have been drinking it for 30
years
so you can easily find you can easily
just send out you know a questionnaire
to gp surgeries to doctor surgeries to
hospitals and they can you know
obviously if people lie that's up to
them but the point is is if you get a
large enough cohort where you go back
you know 20 25 30 years and you go back
and you look what's happened to their
health and you compare it to other
people of a similar demographic and you
look back what's happened to their
health
that is very easily done we don't need
to wait another 20 30 years for that to
happen but the point is is that if there
was a serious effect the observational
research we have so far would have shown
something massive
right so in the future we might see tiny
increases in specific conditions or
specific types of cancers but
realistically a 10 relative increase
risk of a cancer where you've only got
one percent risk anyway you're looking
at a 1.1
risk like that's not you know that's not
actually changing anything for the
record that hasn't been found
no it's not been found it's not been
found across the totality of evidence
for example the study that i cited
earlier in 2022 on the french population
they're suggesting that sweetness cause
a 14 or 15 percent relative
increased risk but then there's a meta
analysis in last year of 10 individual
studies by leaping
um in 2021 showing that actually some
sweeteners cause a reduced risk of
urinary system cancer so there's even
the inverse
so you need to look at all of the data
in its entirety and not just you know
hold these kind of opinions based on
you know one or two articles you see or
one you know doctor or professional
saying something because you need to
bring the evidence simple and let me
just piggyback on what love was saying
i'm curious how long did it take there
was definitely a period of time when
people were like cigarettes smoking is
good for you and doc your favorite
doctor smokes this brand so how long was
that period of time before they're like
oh [ __ ] this is actually really bad for
you
oh with the smoking thing it's a
difficult one because
there's obviously you know these notions
that people were paid off and different
studies were you know
they were you know trying to support the
tobacco industry and so i can't really
say anything concrete about that however
with the research you know
procedures we have in place for example
you know even if it's funded by an
industry there are lots of journals that
require that paper to have an
independent statistician an independent
researcher you sign forms saying that
you have no input into how the study is
carried out so that we have lots of
procedures in place where we can
actually minimize the impact that
industry has on the research going
forward so back then that wasn't really
a thing you know researchers didn't have
to disclose their
their uh conflicts of interest they
didn't have to disclose where the
funding came from but now things are
pretty robust now you can you can find
out things quickly that's interesting
and doctor my last question for you is
are you single
uh i am uh i am single lots of thirsting
for you i don't know what you want to do
with that information but uh how what's
data what's dating like as a doctor it's
got to help a lot right
the thing is um
because of my because of my religious
background
i am you know how do we say in the west
you're saving yourself for the world oh
so are you a virgin doctor
yes wow
keeping it hello yes let's go so okay
interesting and what how old are you may
i ask
i'm a prime 27
20 oh my god you're so young what the
[ __ ]
how did you accomplish all that by 27
through
you know seven eight years of intense
learning the highest level education
working with people
yeah 27. and is it hard to find the time
to date you sound so busy
honestly i when i come back from work
i'm straight away on my laptop either
i'm scripting i'm writing i'm
researching
recording
uh or i'm planning my next week of worth
of content and then i go to bed where do
you
how can we how can you meet women right
what's the plan to you know what i mean
we got to get you know make sure you're
set up
yeah the thing is
you know the city where i am
people know like people just know
everyone through everyone right small
town so
no it's actually well birmingham's
actually a massive town okay it's a
massive city but like just the way in
which our culture is kind of set up you
know you go to loads of different friend
functions and different social occasions
and events it's very easy like to meet
people outside of work and then also the
hospital environment is massive
you know you've got loads of different
professions coming in and out all the
time
so yeah it should have you know it won't
be too difficult
are people always trying to set you up
with their daughters do you get a lot of
like suitors or whatever i've
got to be popular
i've had a few patients and staff
suggest that yeah
i have a condom nothing good eh nothing
good's coming i mean uh you know the
thing is it's pretty inappropriate when
when you're the doctor yeah yeah
of course and uh you know to start to
start saying oh yeah show me a picture
of of whoever you're talking about yeah
you're too professional for that yeah
yeah
you can't do that you can't do that can
i can i ask you um what faith it is you
practice
yes i'm muslim so islam
[Laughter]
it seems that you're relatively um
uh uh what's the word devo or uh pious
right is this fair to say
do you ever find that
your
devotion to your religion and what you
believe as a muslim person
is that odds with any of the medical
research you do or any anything like
that do the two worlds clash at all
yeah interesting that's that's actually
a very it's a very interesting topic
because
a lot of things that are that have been
you know established in my religion
earlier on for example the benefits of
you know black seed oil or honey and
it's you know and antibacterial
properties actually we're starting to
see that a lot of these things are
lining up with modern western science
now
and i've not seen anything that
contradicts what my religion has said in
from a scientific health standpoint but
obviously you know i can't i can't talk
about a lot of those things because
they're not established in modern
medicine yet
so i don't want to you know cause
because obviously my whole thing is
advising based on scientific evidence
right so i can't then go and advise
based on prophetic guidance
i need to wait until the science
actually backs it up
and that has been the case with lots of
you know traditional things dates honey
black seed oil
vinegar consumption a lot of these
things we are now seeing have legitimate
benefits so and has there ever been
anything that kind of got debunked by
your research
i personally haven't i haven't number
one looked into it as much as i would
like to now that you've told me i do
actually want to go back and look at the
research for a lot of these things even
things like you know turmeric
and active compound curcumin inside we
know now from the past 20 years that it
has tremendous
anti-inflammatory anti-cancer
antioxidant benefits so i haven't found
anything that contradicts um and
you know i'm you know i'm going to
continue basically sieving through the
science and making sure that things
actually do align and and and finally uh
you're a resident of uk do you eat beans
on toast and how frequently
[Laughter]
beans on toast um i don't eat beans on
toast but it is actually a pretty staple
it's a it's a pretty staple kind of
childhood
growing up
meal
from parents
basically yeah yeah you see you skip
you're skipping the beans on toast we're
saying no to that although probably
probably it has a lot of the beans on
toast has pork in it eh
does it
i think here a lot of it has like bacon
or i think that's bad i think i remember
when we looked into it that wasn't the
case in the uk but was here
is it pork is it what is it pork fat
pulp extract inside beans what is it
they just add it for flavor
here i mean in america we get buck wild
with it we do
there's a lot it's common to put bacon
in the baked beans here and stuff like
that yeah i think the heinz
beans are just tomato
yeah so not all of them i think yeah
yeah you would yeah which is the the
standard over here yeah i mean do they
say that on the packaging because that's
a big problem i think they say i think
they probably it would list it on the
bacon or yeah yeah for sure for sure
oh okay fine because imagine you've got
a million vegans having some beans and
yeah
well doctor uh we've taken so much of
your time and we're so appreciative
you know
uh thank you thank you for for
everything and round two and we really
appreciate thank you very much love do
you have any us beloved do you want to
uh resort to anything he brought up do
you want to
no i don't really want to retort i
there's this book that i read like way
back it's called like industrial string
uh denial industrial revolution in the
in its context
and that's where a lot of my skeptical
thinking comes from it's like all these
like industrial lawyers like protecting
stuff like coal industry radio
consumption all this stuff and that's
kind of where i don't know i basically
don't have anything against what you're
saying i agree with literally everything
you're saying too so i don't know
thank you thank you very much
so so it's so your kind of viewpoint
stems from the whole
conflict of interest industry funding
you know protection of monetary
interests
that kind of thing right
well see see you're like debunking one
thing and then i say something else i'm
kind of judging everything you say i
[ __ ] i know i'm i'm so much into the
wrong here it's just my brain you're not
in the wrong you're not listening you're
50 to be skeptical yes and 55 of the
people were agreeing with you love you
know so you you shouldn't feel bad
you need to you need to understand that
all of your viewpoints that all of you
have said i've had hundreds of times in
my comments
like they're not right
they're not uncommon viewpoints right
and this is why i need to cover diet
coke and diet drinks every month i
literally did it the other day
from this flav city guy who also spouts
a lot of nonsense right i've seen that
guy bobby bobby whatever his name is
um he just walks around a grocery store
and just picks up anything just a
that's carnival md who i'm going to
debate actually we're trying to organize
a debate with him he's not an md though
right he just and he is he is and he
eats just meat right
he he eats ramen mainly
yeah he eats meat and
raw
raw dairy
and honey
and a few fruits and he's an md does
that blow your mind that he's an md
it does it does because i think when
i've had discussions and i've i've
refuted his videos about four times he's
seen all of them and he's made little
digs at me in the past
he knows that the strength of the
evidence is not in his favor
but he will happily cherry-pick a really
rubbish observational study that shows
you know raw milk decreases the rates of
asthma in children to then make an
entire video about it and he'll ignore
everything i said
so and the reason he does that is
because he has us he he has a supplement
company he has a book
you know here it is
he's kind of pioneering the movement
with liver king
i wanted to ask you about liver king is
he healthy
um
the thing is in my opinion he's on a lot
of uh performance-enhancing anabolic
steroids
he is no he's all natural how dare you
um yeah and the thing is is that the
logic his logic stems from this whole
ancestry
way is the best way and it's like okay
bro they lived till they were 19 years
old
right the like
didn't see once exactly
and the thing is is that he makes a lot
of money i'm talking like a million two
million per month just from just from
his supplements right right yeah so even
if he found out he was wrong which i'm
sure he does know deep inside he is
wrong
he would not go back on his word it's
just too late yeah he's committed now
he's playing the character yeah and he
works now with carnival md on on some
things love that for them so
it'd be interesting to see how long they
live right i mean
probably not that long huh the thing is
the thing is
to be honest because the traditional
western diet is heavily
ultra processed you know fast food fried
foods excess refined sugar
literally if you compare that diet with
literally any other dietary pattern keto
vegan intermittent fasting carnivore
whatever
you will probably improve your health
probably
that's actually an interesting point
exactly so the thing is is that even
though i don't advocate for the
carnivore diet
anyone going from a western diet to a
carnivore diet it's kind of like going
to diet coke isn't it
yes
yes exactly no it's true because because
you're substituting your calories
from fried refined sugar candy biscuits
sweets to you know raw meat
okay cool like okay raw meat might not
be the best for you you it will contain
pathogens it might increase your risk of
cancer but it's it's probably better
than whatever a lot of the western are
consuming that's it that's actually
that's really good explanation for why
people do these crazy diets and they're
like i'm losing weight i'm feeling good
it's probably because you're not eating
[ __ ] funyuns for breakfast
yeah and you try you try eating 3 000
calories worth of raw testicles i bet i
bet you
hey can i host the debate between you
guys where's when is that set to go
uh we're actually talking about it i
mean it depends if you're interested in
heavily scientific debates listen i'm
just going to moderate it
oh heavily scientific yeah
it might not be the best choice but but
but but maybe we can have another one on
our show that's not like more like you
know for love of the game unless like
we're actually talking to liver king
maybe we could have dr ed speak with
liver king eventually i think liver
would dodge
the thing is the thing is i need someone
who can actually understand the science
because
i can't like having a conversation with
someone like that it will literally be
like playing chess with a pidgin
i can make the best move i can make the
best move possible but he'll strut
around knock over some pieces and think
he's won exactly so familiar we just saw
it to be just like that last week so
yeah
um yeah but you know what um
i actually i think i think you're
discounting how entertaining it would be
uh you guys do your science thing
between the two of you i'm inviting you
guys formally i'll moderate it
impartially
i would love
let's have this debate guy i'm ready
maybe he's interested
my only condition is that he has to do
it without a shirt
okay um right so so are you thinking of
like a separate shortened segment that's
less scientific no no we will do the
debate here on the show
and and are you is your audience happy
for me to literally go into the actual
mechanism the in-depth science
you know
like i'm talking i'm talking pretty just
scientifically yeah pretty stuff yeah
might not be the best forum for well
where are you guys planning on doing it
i want to be involved i want to see this
[ __ ]
so
you know some of some of the some of the
more kind of um scientific podcasts like
you know the hubermann lab or you know
things like uh more plates more dates or
um one of the you know mine what's it
kind of mindful mindless podcast or
something a lot of these kind of bigger
kind of wellness and fitness podcast i
actually talk about the science how how
long are you guys set to debate for
it'll be probably an hour oh we could do
that
we could do that
what bet there's we're getting a big
play who watches these [ __ ] uh
medical positions oh i agree it's a big
platform
i don't
i don't necessarily myself feel
qualified to moderate a highly technical
debate but but maybe but dude moderators
are always dumb bro oh i don't know like
seriously you ever see the moderators
and the debates are always the dumbest
person in the room okay
that's kind of true
i think the the the most important part
of the moderator would be to basically
ensure that
we stick to the topics at hand right and
he doesn't just end up straw manning my
argument basically taking one small
aspect and just going on a massive
tangent um ethan is pretty good at that
thank you dan
it's the first nice thing you said about
me in
a decade i've known you
i don't know why i'm so competitive
today let's do it if he's interested i'd
love to have you guys on it'll be
fantastic well he he messaged me the
other day for the first time being like
uh
hey man he said hey man why don't we
stop you know bickering on social media
and come on
and have an actual
and i said i said i'm more than happy to
but it's not going to be on your podcast
which you run and you host perhaps
absolutely not look it sounds like he
wants to get clouded up and this is a
good place to do it
yeah yeah i just hope you number 12
podcasts in the world
yeah no that's that's a very good point
um
yeah i will i will actually send him a
voice message after this and say look
you know we've got we've got a third
party yes yeah hopefully hopefully
neither pro carnival or you know
whatever i'll pledge to be you know
impartial and just focus on
keeping
people on on on point right like you
said
yes that that that would be probably
wise yeah um but yeah yeah it's a shame
it's a shame that he does he he has gone
down the way he has gone down can i ask
you a question um
what is the craziest diet you see right
now and i i for me it's the
the raw meat diet which became really
popular i mean the likes of people like
jordan peterson are proudly talking
about they eat raw
[ __ ] meat and he goes it cured my
depression that he isn't raw though he's
just oh just me he's yeah 100 carnivores
so he probably
because a lot of those raw i think liver
king probably does eat like small
amounts of he it's raw liver right but
his
yeah but then there's the carnivore diet
which is just a hundred i don't eat
anything but steak and chicken which is
the dude you're debating he just eats
raw meat do any of these guys eat raw
chicken
ah god i hope not that's gotta be
difficult
[Music]
i think i think even if you choose to
ignore the evidence i think you'd be
stupid to just try that for a bit of
clout yeah yeah um
yeah
red meat red meat you have less of an
issue
but death and fish as well fish is
most mostly completely fine but uh
chicken that's probably one meat you
don't want to be consuming wrong so if
he wants to i'd like to see him eating
raw chicken if he wants to impress me
i mean i can i can put that i can put
that listen if you want to prove your
car in the world let's start getting
those raw
thighs down and prove to me what kind of
growth and impress me that way
no but um
yeah
what's the crazy diet you see though
right now
craziest diet you were you're like what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
um
by problem
an actual dietary pattern is probably
[Music]
uh
either a raw veg or a raw meat diet
probably
or
there are you know these massive trends
of like kind of
internal showers where you're just
literally
just swallowing like bucket loads of
chia seeds and water
and your internal shower
yeah you're basically defecating your
brains out and that's how people think
you detox your body
um
right it's very very strange there's
been lots of lots of viral videos saying
this is how you clean out your system
and you just basically poo your pants
out that's all you do for no reason
well they think it feels good for them
and it you know gets rid of basically
they have the logic that we have living
worms inside our gut
that are causing chronic illness and
these parasites are leaching into our
blood our bones our muscle
and that's why you have chronic illness
yeah that one's pretty crazy yes you're
right
yeah and and then you click on their
link tree and they're selling a
parasitic cleanse for a hundred dollars
oh but there always comes down always a
grip
what about anime you don't people do
coffee animals does that blow your mind
that's one that always kind of shocks me
you're fairly popular
is it
oh yeah coffee enema you guys have heard
of that right i've seen it i've heard of
it yeah no it's a thing people do it's i
think it's like
in terms of like alt medicine i think
it's popular
so just to clarify that they're putting
up the back side yes yes yeah and they
soak they put it in
the enema and they soak it they keep it
in for as long as they can and then they
release
that sounds horrific yeah
yeah yep what are the benefits of that
no no no no it's all kind of
everything boosts immunity and increases
energy are the claims yeah yeah sure
yeah increase energy you're soaking in a
whole pot of coffee up your ass what the
[ __ ] that's not a surprise
yeah interestingly enough there are some
drugs that actually work very
effectively up the bum right and that's
you know caffeine being a stimulant
probably probably does the same however
the the claim that it you know
uh
cleans you out kind of
detoxes you but relieves constipation if
you're constipated you don't need to
stick things up your bum you need to
focus on what you're going in through
your mouth that's what you need to focus
on why are you just basically an enema
just relieves the symptoms of
constipation right you're not actually
fixing the root issue of why you're
constipated in the first place
let's focus on the b hole more focus on
the m hole
yes
exactly
and people often talk out of their bum
as well so let's let's not do that
and um let me ask
you're on tick tock a lot so this is
interesting people are wondering your
opinion on pink sauce are you aware of
what that is
i've i've had several comments about
that i don't know what it is what is it
um
did we are we were we able to get a
bottle of that stuff is it in the mail
or something yes so there's like this
mystery sauce maybe maybe you can help
find something pulled up yeah it's like
a sauce that went viral on tick tock
that a woman was selling through her
small business and it was just the color
pink and everybody was like wow so cute
it's literally the color of pepto
business yeah i've never seen
yeah anything edible this color
supposedly it's made with dragon fruit
which makes it pink here we go i got i
got one for you thank you okay um
here's what it looks like
apparently it's a top being oh it's like
uh
you put it on chicken consistency of
like mayonnaise almost yeah people say
it tastes like ranch
but but people would get it in the mail
and it would be a completely different
color rotten gross oh for real she got
sick and she she essentially just posted
like an apology saying that she's a
small business
and she's not fda approved
yeah of course
yeah yeah fda pro
because
what is she i mean is it just a taste
thing is it what like what is it i think
it was just the color of it made it
interesting what can make a food this
color i mean besides food coloring it's
dragon fruit dragon fruit supposedly
that's what she says no way
that i mean that
it looks pretty concentrated to be
yeah yeah i mean i wouldn't be surprised
if there wasn't some kind of food
coloring or food dye in it
yeah that color is cr i've never seen i
mean that's nuts it's like cotton candy
and pepto-bismol that's it
hopefully she's not claiming any health
claims
is it just a condiment or she doing like
is she saying it good for you supposedly
yeah no no i think it's just a condiment
yeah it's just a condiment
okay good so that that doesn't need
debunking then no no no i guess not okay
yeah okay well we we we got to the
bottom of the pink sauce situation
um
doctor once again thank you for calling
what time is it there i know you you've
been up you stayed up it's uh half a
it's 11 38 p.m nice well thank you so
much and what what time you go to bed
are you up but you you stay up late for
us
uh no no
one usually uh on a work night okay um
but yeah is there
anyone that has any issues amongst the
crew
with
dire drinks
because if i see the chat popping off
again
gonna be fun he doesn't want to have to
come back a third time no no we're good
no we're sold does anyone else i'm never
drinking water again you're like a
gladiator does anyone have something to
say
i actually stand by what i say as well
because i don't drink water i drink this
all day every day
right you don't even drink water
no because i love it why would i drink
water if i just can have this oh this
man doesn't drink water he just drinks
diet kool-aid that's great
shout the [ __ ] out doctor it lives that
[ __ ] he's not just saying it he lives it
y'all
yeah my blood tests my blood tests are
all good you look yeah you look healthy
i mean you look great uh what's the
sweetener in that is it aspartame
um i think here they've got yes they do
have some brands that have
um aspartame and they've got some that
contain sucralose
um
they're the main ones i think that are
used here but all of the ones you guys
have in america we have all of the same
yeah yeah yeah in uk as well there's not
like some massive u.s conspiracy that
you've you've got special kind of
sweeteners you don't right and um well
people want to pull so let's see if you
came back and swayed
the people so once again let's do the
pull dan one
diet coke and you tell me if this poll
is fair okay because we get complaints
that we have do bad pulls
one
is that um diet coke
is fine
it's safe it's safe diet coke is
safe that's great yes and then or
diet coke is not safe
yes yes or diet coke causes harm yeah or
something a diet calculus causes heart
causes yeah
the most annoying straw man argument i
get in my comments all the time is
oh is this really a doctor saying that
diet drinks are good for you
that that is literally not what i've
said at all i've said that replacing
calories from sugar sweetened beverages
going to a diet drink can improve your
health
i'm not saying that the actual diet
drink itself has any inherent positive
benefits on your health right right
right i think we all understand that
elimination of the sugar all right so
the poll
is up all right and then love and av let
me know what you voted for around loving
a b what did you vote
well i didn't vote go ahead and vote
you vote either of these sir either i
can't vote for the other one because i
don't think it's harmful i don't think
either i'm hesitant
uh if you were forced to vote at
gunpoint which one would you vote for
diet coke is safe
okay play okay and a b is that that yeah
what is the chat what does the chat want
me to vote
the chat is has turned around diet coke
is okay then i'm with chad i'm with the
chat let's let's go
this poll is different than the other
one though because the other one was is
it safe well that was a bad pull up i'm
still bad i'm still hesitant
that was a bad poll that we have you're
skeptical so maybe we should reword it
are you still skeptical of diet coke or
we no no no
diet coke is safe obviously massive win
congratulations dr edds uh you've
influenced a lot of people here today
but but let's just let's just word it
because that was a bad pull potentially
shad is going to hate me are you
skeptical are you skeptical
about diet coke
diet coke still
yes
no
i am still skeptical
yes yes yes
or even you can even put it lighter i
still have some reservations
nope yep
right and then yes should be i've seen
the light
what's the other way around yes should
be i've ascended i still have
still have reservations they're with
this doctor okay okay this is important
right i mean this is a good no no
i literally made a viral video like two
days ago and the comments were just
atrocious i i had to close the app oh
yeah so
yeah we can we can't allow that
so dan we got to pull up
so this is as we're as we do now i feel
like this is way worse than doctors
right there better not be any typos in
there are you skeptical about diet coke
still
yes i still have reservations or no it's
all good so i'm voting no it's all good
love you would probably based on what
you told me say i still have some
reservations right yes
yeah okay so that that gives love and
out okay and then a b what would you
vote was it chat one
baby come on vote b be your own man yeah
bm
it's not easy
when i can't talk [ __ ] back to the chat
not to you doctor to the chat
um
you're getting too involved with them
well have we talked about oral health or
stomach lining
are you skeptical
i'm still a little sick okay so you're
voting new vectors here at the last just
to say
just to say
the carbonation effects is a completely
different topic because there are lots
of there are lots of things like that's
not a that's not a discussion about
sweeteners that's nothing to do with the
calories yeah well because because this
doesn't have any carbonation right smart
so there you go there you go smartest
doctor well that goes back to my
original statement that's that's stuff i
was talking about well he's right though
the carbonation whether that's bad for
you
is probably a different conversation
that's next week's episode got it okay
yeah a simple way a simple way around
that is to drink through a straw done
oh
interesting through a straw found next
well there you go doesn't what about
some people would say drinking i'm not
saying it does i'm asking if it does if
it affects stomach lining at all
no no no no not really obviously
once again dose the dose is the poison
so right right yeah and some people say
drinking through a straw is a little bit
beta what would you say to that
uh well if you want good teeth in your
60s then drink through a straw okay
there you have it
i have an issue in morals right now
because uh if i were to live my normal
life i would never share false
information on a podcast in front of the
four thousand forty
no i just want to explain this because i
think it's fun
uh normally i would i would just keep
this in my own brain i wouldn't infect
anyone else with possibly faking or
probably fake information i'll just keep
it in my own brain but now uh you're
doing it for some reason
yeah well no because
we won't hold it against you like i just
i just want to explain my philosophy
there uh that normally i wouldn't tell
anyone about this information but now
i'm telling 45 for 40 000 people and now
i'm going against my own morals 40
785 people right no it's good it's good
because you are the voice of any
comments 42
of the people voted they're still
skeptical exactly exactly yeah exactly
dr ridge i'm curious do you have fun
light in the uk
um i've not heard of that fun light it's
like the juice you were talking about i
it's pretty much the exact same thing
you you blend it with water and yeah no
sugar in there i drink it all the time
so just like you know those low calorie
drops that you just drop into water it's
just like that
yeah well doctor i don't know you can
see the poll but this one's a lot closer
43 percent say i still have reservations
that's still a flip from earlier though
we have moved the needle though
uh no it's all good 57
so okay yeah that's that's an
improvement not as high as i'd like it
do you think it's fair to have
reservations at this point just speaking
of don't don't not worry about offending
anyone but like you saying is do you
think it's like
fair be like yeah okay i get you still
have reservations you're like you really
shouldn't have any more reservations
the thing is i would say based on the
strength of the evidence
that we have available um
the thing is because i'm in this i'm in
the research field and
you know i understand that you can't
call something conclusive like literally
a hundred percent conclusive
i i would probably need
you know maybe some more
longitudinal research meaning over a
prolonged period of time
on a few specific disease outcomes maybe
some specific types of cancer or maybe
some
specific types of you know glycemic
control or something
i i'm happy to say on a public health
advice platform that diet drinks are
safe but my internal scientist brain
is wanting some more evidence to confirm
that conclusion okay okay okay so
reserve saying you still have
reservations is not even uh
necessarily a crazy thing to say it's
human yeah so i don't have i don't have
reservations from telling people that
it's safe yeah yeah i haven't i have an
internal reservation in my own academic
brain
where i you know i i i would say that
the evidence for vegetables being
beneficial for health far outweighs the
evidence that sweeteners are safe
basically
so there are you know there are levels
to evidence that we have well i have
empirical evidence that vegetables are
bad and pizza is good
and i can back it up with uh
[Music]
but you can add you can add four
servings of vegetables on a pizza anyway
so pizza is actually very nutritious
that's papa john papa john came on our
show are you are you wearing papa john
out in the uk
yeah we have we have we have pajamas and
he came on our show and he said pizza is
actually very nutritious your thoughts
on that
there's this i don't know if you can
hear the sound bite
can you hear that i think i think it
sends the sound back to the zoom guy
that's actually very nutritious
oh yeah i had that yeah
the thing is
the thing is is
the pizzas that they sell
especially with the high saturated fat
in the cheese they have butter uh
dipping sauce it's just melted butter
yeah
i think a very simple fix for those
types of pizzas is just to replace it
with a low saturated fat cheese and a
lower calorie cheese and to be honest
most pizzas can be healthy oh my god
he has no pizza
i [ __ ] love this guy
dr itz but once again are you consuming
a large pizza by yourself yes that's the
question yes okay well then because well
then
you know literally
even if you were to consume 4 000
calories of apples every day right for
two years your health wouldn't be in a
good state right so it's the fact that
you're over eating it's not necessarily
the food itself right yeah that's a good
stay tuned
yeah that's that's the important point
pizza inherently is not harmful or bad
for you
it's just it's the it's the ease of
consumption you eat four of those slices
you're way over your calories
yeah well yeah that's you know two or
three is what they recommend for a
serving right so
yeah that's too little
and and and how are we feeling about uh
melted butter garlic sauce is that a
good topping for pizza
uh probably not
oh damn papa damn
all right doctor once again but once
again only in
only because it's very easy to consume
it in a large quantity that's why right
right well doctor again i thank you so
much guys please check out
dr
idz
on tik tok uh his tick tock's awesome
you guys will definitely not regret
following him there doctor thank you so
much if we have other medical questions
or food debates uh would you be happy to
to join again i was actually looking
forward to debate a doctor because i
would let him know
what evidence they're basing their
claims on because chances are i've read
the study that they're talking about and
chances are i'll be able to critique it
as well i i i'm serious about having you
guys on this is going to be such
you know
let's let's make it happen let's make it
happen yeah let me let me send him a
voicemail after this we'll see what he
has to say okay thank you doctor
appreciate your time
and uh we'll talk to you soon hopefully
all right it's been a pleasure thanks
guys thank you thank you
wow what an experience you know i knew
this diet coke conversation was heated
but this is incredible we've had an
engaged conversation for what feels like
definitely over an hour oh yeah way more
probably an hour and a half yeah and i
earned 20.
now a b and love you guys are feeling
i've sensed that you guys are feeling a
little bit bad about uh no no i feel
good saying mean things about you guys
no no i don't care oh no
there's a sizeable amount of the chat
that like we saw in that last poll it
still has reservations so this is not to
be honest i didn't want to step in on it
but i felt the same way as love but i
kind of feel like when we split the
ridicule it's not as bad so i commend
you love for speaking up i know you said
that you don't like to but i feel like
it keeps the show interesting yeah i
made that conversation on that thing
that was
yeah exactly it made it so much better
that you guys were
expressing your reservation
and here is our two patron saints
dr eggs
and martin the water uh sommelier
and these are two titans of industry
that are through
yeah
uh no thank you for expressing both of
you guys i hope that you know i
appreciate it yeah thank you thank you
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message to anybody
drinking diet coke right now
i want to tell you please
after the 20th of october diet coke will
not cause harm
any diet coke that arrives after 20th
october will be drinking
please i'm telling you with peace and
love diet coke is totally fine thank you
thank you peace and love peace and love
peace and
love yep
oh i wanted to thank by the way um
uh
gm pigeon
is that our saudi benefactor i couldn't
tell
if that's a meme or not 50 gifted yeah
[Applause]
wait who's pigeon though doctor it's oh
he said yeah like paint jessica pigeon
yeah
yo i really hope that debate comes here
yeah that would be so awesome it would
be fun
seeing third eye blind
why that's a weird comment
i remember you when you used to spend
the whole goddamn day
in bed
yeah
wow that was we have so much to talk
about but ultimately dr ids
was the star wasn't he
uh yeah i gotta give a shout out to chad
real quick because at first i got some
uh like pushback and i was a little bit
uns shaky you know but then the chat
shows super much love and i just [ __ ]
when you're doing something like this
you've got you can't look at the chat
yeah you can't let them get in your head
no i it's not like so much that i don't
and i think
love is the same way it's not so much
that it bothers us like
making us want to change our opinion but
just that like it's so stupid that you
want to respond like when they're saying
that we're anti-vex they're comparing us
bro you can't read it bro you know you
read the chat sure you don't get both
especially when you're debating
something or anything you know you got
to just minimize it when that's going on
yeah yeah yeah
that was fun though i gotta say
yeah it was good that's a good guy right
there
eligible bachelor
oh yeah
why urgent man he's gonna have a fat nut
once he's married
oh yeah although i wonder if he yeah
i wanna i wonder if he's allowed to
masturbate do you know the answer to
that ab
i don't know
lina do you know that
milk no i don't know either can you call
the chef in our home can we get him back
on the call
no not for that when he doesn't waste
that then i'll take everything he says
it's the word of god
isn't the whole point that oh
nice that once he busts the nut then
i'll be for sure to take him serious
yeah dude i will gotta talk to him after
we're gonna send him a nice wedding gift
i'll be watching him no he's because
he's like a good guy yeah
just curious just saying the same just
probably not allowed
because the whole point is that you're
not going to have sex for pleasure yeah
try to factor a little bit it depends
which you follow are muslims allowed to
masturbate and what you're masturbating
to like is it your imagination i would
have to guess
no porn for sure no yeah just
imagination do not come
this is not
approved i'm gonna come
we i don't think christianity inherently
bans masturbation but some of the
more extreme sex do right yeah i kind of
don't want to fact check this because
it's going to be one of those things
like ignorance
it's not a sin if i don't know you know
what i mean
you think it would get in your head if
they're like yo you shouldn't masturbate
and you're like oh like it's you know
excuse i didn't know so i don't yeah
don't don't look it up don't look i need
someone else to do this one i won't take
that from you
i'm gonna come
yeah i want to take that from you
appreciate it
i am curious to answer though but i'll
look i'll look i'll look at home you
don't need to know on your own
yeah look at my own thing
it says i mean some people say no it's
not i i
curiosity got to me mrs quran talks
about in detail sexual uh stuff but does
not mention uh masturbation anywhere so
you're good
according to this but again there's
gonna be 50 muslims in the comments okay
no that's i mean yeah everyone's got
different opinions about that poor man i
mean if you can't
even jerk off bro
hold on i'm coming
i just wouldn't understand
how
pretty disrespectful and invasive guys
hey how about you [ __ ] invade these
nuts
[Applause]
oh yeah so obviously um jimmy lee and my
dad had a pow-wow that was totally off
the rails they pulled the picture
uh where was that photo
jimmy lee posted a pretty crazy photo
it's great but also pretty crazies can
take a lot of editing you guys
these guys are not tr media's savvy
they're not trained uh right
uh
uh
you may need
cameron you may how long do you think
you're gonna need for that one probably
like at least like two weeks right
i could probably get it done by later
next week
yeah it's a lot of work
um but it was i think it's gonna end up
being something really good
where's the picture you posted with my
dad you took it down already let me see
or did he just post that much
he just oh my god he does post a lot
yeah that's a lot dude yeah here they
are
the two legends we had to paint jimmy
didn't have his hair makeup so we
provided the hairline for him
and then you know i didn't want to make
him feel bad because my dad has a pretty
good hairline for his age
and uh
i didn't want anyone to feel conscious
so we filled in my dad's hair a little
bit too i've fallen
and i'm all special
there you have it
it's gonna be good it's gonna be crazy
did you notice that he made his hairline
a little bit darker there too to make it
seem more natural yeah did he photoshop
it a little bit yes loved that
loved that for him
but he was a he was a trooper man oh you
know what's crazy we met jimmy's kids
they were here he has two like i would
say
upper teen or one of them's 22 and one
of them is like a teenager one's in uh
22 in college becoming a dentist and
then the other just graduated high
school
super nice guys well adjusted
his hands were great yeah which was nuts
i was like how the [ __ ] do you guys come
from jimmy lee like super well adjusted
his wife must be a saint that's what he
said yeah
oh yeah my dad
my dad sam you might be funny to know
this my dad has been unable to get the
color out of his hair
he said he washed it four times i keep
telling him to send me a picture
but he won't do it he said he's out at a
dodger game and he
says he's like i refuse to take off my
hat
but hello he said he sent a picture said
that it lasts through the next wash
i don't know if that means it goes away
after the next wash or if it let me send
you there's a few that need to happen i
have one photo he said he washed his
hair four times so i don't know i mean
it looked good so i mean hold that up
dan yeah
well i think it looks pretty sweet when
he tried to wash it out it looks like
he's got like kind of a cool auburn
thing going on here oh that does look
good
look at his slick ass
hair
oh it looks fine yeah it looks fine i
agree he's being dramatic
and in the role of a lifetime gary klein
in the role
oh that's interesting that's good
gary and they're all of a lifetime and
the role of a lifetime gary
that's awesome
listen what else is there to say um
we obviously had a lot to talk about but
we got to like nothing today we [ __ ]
slammed sometimes you just got to follow
those interesting uh threads right
absolutely
apologies we made we had some debates
lots of good stuff yeah
i want to once again say that tomorrow
morning teddy fresh 10 am pst
the new collection will come out and you
can be the proud owner of this elon musk
is a piece of shirt
swag
let the world know
loser
l
totally
take the gift
thank you for the good
yeah and shout out to ninja of course
and thank you a b and love for sticking
your neck i you know i appreciate it i
just i don't you know you guys shouldn't
feel bad you guys shouldn't even listen
to chat everyone's happy you go to
comments after
chat is very reactive they get caught up
in the moment hey b stock killer thing
with the prime thank you thank you thank
you thank you it's true
we're good i'm glad i'm just not alone
in my controversial takes it's not
controversial you're fine i'll die stop
it diet being bad is very controversial
it's very bad
all righty thank you guys thank you
thank you for uh being here what a nice
show fun show
good show
wholesome show powerful show powerful
slick show neat show powerful
we made up with a lot of enemies we
created some new ones
which new ones did we create
liver king yeah maybe liver king i mean
dave porter and then dave pork dick
although he was sort of in the enemy
column already and was sort of edging
his way back i feel like he did a spike
down so he lives on the line between
almost bestie and enemy
he's kind of he's like a he's an
anti-hero
listen to this
ethan
i have some fantastic news
breaking news thank you
as you know i sent an email we sent a
nice email a very polite
but firm email requesting that they
removed the copyright strike
zero minutes ago i just happened to open
gmail a response we will remove the
strike immediately i apologize for the
miscommunication i
oh my god said it
i can't [ __ ] believe with honey than
vinegar
i cannot [ __ ] believe how being nice
is working out in life
i don't see it up by the way still yeah
he needs to come in on wednesday now
well
i'm not exaggerating zero minutes ago i
just got this email should we we should
probably stay live until it goes live
yes
go ahead here's an idea guys we have to
boost pork boy's feet score back up to
at least three stars well i gotta see
the proof in the pudding before we start
right i mean this is this is but but
thank you oh my god what's her name
olivia i heard well you don't want to
say your name oh well he just did what's
her oh that's her name her name is
olivia yes this is olivia olivia at bar
stool and dave portnoy i'll respectfully
use your name
wow please friendship i mean this is
powerful stuff hold on
oh yeah yeah yeah let's get over there
yeah
wait
wait hold on hold on hold on let's open
up
it's so true that you can catch more
flies with honey wait wait hold on hold
on what's happening
is the mic on at least yeah okay
it's just so true isn't it and i'm
learning i feel like i'm learning an
important thing in life you just if you
nice then you could get down so nice
things back
right
and so with that being said i i want to
give a heartfelt apology
to dave portnoy and i would use his name
respectfully as god as his mother gave
it to him his surname respectfully
i think the one above it works now he'd
be yeah thank you okay
[Music]
by the way shout out abe he's been
putting in
time cleaning the office so it looks
good for the uh
my bffs
so thank you ab for that
you know my pleasure yeah thank you bro
always hustling um i do want to say you
know wow
and i thought deep felt
i'm calling off the war
thank you dave portnoy
stand by
i'm waiting for it to come in but once
that comes in just tell i'm just telling
you right now that foot score perfect
foot
[Music]
yeah
i don't know what to say i mean this is
this is really a change
changing everything for me
thank you thank you to bar stool i love
bar stool uh their coverage yeah of
everything is superb and there's a
reason they're they're so big they are
yeah pete's reviews are great
thanks to his leadership right
david may i call you david respectfully
david
such a fearless leader funny
charismatic
mm-hmm
can we go to go pets
go cats i don't know what that means go
pets oh go pats whatever i'm brady's the
greatest quarterback of all time
that's not flattering picture guys come
on we're being trying to make we're
that's a disrespectful photo oh my god
there's aren't there many pictures of
him for some reason you know i kind of
like this the black background it's raw
it's just you and your apology
it's raw
what did garth said what is this what
did garth brooks say
uh cool raw slick let the conversation
begin anyway you know stuff yeah this i
mean thank you and and and beautiful job
with the email dan that was wonderfully
worded and shout out to my guy youtube
i'll be honest he said why don't you
reach out to them and at first i was
like nah [ __ ] that but i was like you
know what
i'll write i will write them and i was
provided by the name of the or the email
the person that made the dmca which is
what you you legally have to provide
that anyway
and dan wrote a really beautiful email
more beautiful than kim jong-un
letter to donald trump
[Music]
and
in that email was
poetry a corpse of a dove
i mean it was alive at one point thank
you dan an olive branch
dan has been fantastic thank you god i
just is it back up yeah
let's take a look
okay let's take a look
i'm still not up
go pets
go passing
and we're going to go tampa bay and it
is not
yet i'm sure it's coming though yeah
sure it's coming soon she wouldn't lie
she wouldn't just make that up olivia
wouldn't live like that yeah she's a
girl she's a different great name she
would not do that well that's good there
you love me this is great this is great
news guys let's see news
i will shredder
i'm gonna have pizza for dinner
the course he set his house up in a
strong olive branch
that's what he sent i sent a dove
a dead dove that dove and an olive
branch to olivia
and she received it right
it sounds like he says if you get a
veggie pizza
and he said he said i could eat like
three slices or four did you say four
i think that you would pizza yeah he
used four as an example of too much no i
think he did what did he say love do you
know how much he said he said you could
eat a whole pizza as long as it's salad
on there it's completely healthy
actually that's what he did say yes
we're gonna have to get him back on the
phone
[Laughter]
veggie pizza veggie pizza i'm [ __ ]
thinking about that right now
and also [ __ ] water
[ __ ] that dude the doctor doesn't drink
water he doesn't drink water how epic is
that this man has said no to water my
hero yeah dude i didn't even know you
could do that bro i've been saying no to
water for so long and now i finally feel
validated yep
it doesn't taste that
i could go forever but you got a problem
with water i don't know i've got a few
people in the water all right go ahead i
mean i mean now's the time just i don't
it only tastes good if i'm very thirsty
and when i'm not
it's such a chore i agree and if you
have something you enjoy you're going to
drink a lot more fluid exactly
you're going to sip on it maybe i'm
going to try that squash powder you know
dude that's crazy i'm biting my tongue
right now
i'm gonna hook you guys are you a water
bro
hydration bro or whatever hydro a hydro
homie shredder just went behind the cop
that's that yeah where are you going
shredder
do you see him olivia
shredder
probably didn't take a [ __ ] back there
welcome back right
all right guys thank you so much what a
show i mean what a show it's been
um i'll let you guys know on friday
and i think we need to throw like a we
love
bar stool
party on friday if the video's back up
well we we have a guest on friday but
she could celebrate with us
yeah yeah she'll be happy to join
whitney cummings is coming friday
let's go and it's olivia's birthday on
friday the hilarious but
for birthday on friday oh my god
this is a birthday month for this crew
like all of our birthdays are within the
wonderful and hilarious whitney cummings
she's a a friend and um
a good and a very sweet person
so she's coming on and i think well she
was on once before we had a great time
with her
i think twice
oh she on twitter
yeah it was during lockdown days so
maybe let's call it one and a half
yeah so um please join us friday i think
we'll have a good time
we'll be here tomorrow morning for
leftovers
yeah tomorrow morning we'll be here for
leftovers you know it's hassan's
birthday on monday so that's another
birthday yeah all within like a two
weeks a lot it's kind of a lot i feel so
overwhelmed when a lot of people have
birthdays and i get kind of
stunned i'm like oh i can't i can't do
it there it's done you guys got to
spread your birthdays up more i'll move
mine
yeah can you reschedule it yeah i'll
reschedule mine not a good time for me
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning love you appreciate you y'all
are the best
what a journey we've been on today
absolutely nobody can ever say this
isn't the 12th best show in the world
and we're coming for you number 11. you
watch your [ __ ] back that's right
love all you guys and all you guys on
the crew incredible
incredible talents
every one of them
[Music]
love you too ethan thank you i was gonna
say accept one person as a joke but i'm
not even gonna do that
we all know this is a new ether which
one me
i wasn't even thinking you i wasn't even
gonna go there ib
i wasn't even gonna go there wait who
are you i respect you too much
what he was gonna he was gonna leave it
purposely the thing is
i was thinking of saying ian but he's
not such a talent he's not a talent and
we but i didn't like stated earlier
ian is such a talent i mean you guys
know that i so i didn't say it
[Music]
aren't you glad i wasn't going to say it
about you abby you already said it like
on monday
tonight as a joke yeah [ __ ] so i think
that's got to work on new material
says the wellbutrin is working there you
have it
still fat not working there
well now i'm about to have a pizza right
yeah now to try this new advice it might
help out from a doctor about what you
can eat i know stars talking about i
know this doctor is talking all about
what's make you healthy but i'm about to
gain a lot of weight because of him
no
i doubt it
as long as the salad is on the pizza
exactly
what what qualifies as a salad two
leaves three leaves
something like that how many leaves to
make a salad
[Music]
how many different vegetables like at
what point does a collection of
vegetables become a salad
and that's the kind of the question that
only we can answer here on the issue
podcast
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning
[Music]
even shout out to my family ethan a b
cam dan
gila ian laina olivia sam zack
you